good morning everybody we are going to
begin our subcommittee work session on
HB 369
and the uh
agricultural policy subcommittees all
here
so I'd like to open this up for
discussion
um we had the hearing on establishing a
task force to provide energy relief on
farms
and
um representative Bixby I think you had
some
um
thank you so I did a little bit of
calling around and uh Gathering of more
information I talked with uh Donald
crease who's the um
the uh consumer advocate for energy in
the state and he gave me a number of
um possible you know Avenues and
suggestions to to look into
um one of them uh so uh one of them was
Senator Shaheen's office uh and
Elizabeth McKenna who is a staffer there
specializes in energy stuff I did follow
up with her uh he also suggested that
um it would make sense to work with no
for New Hampshire and the Farm Bureau
and the Farmers Union as possible
um avenues for providing assistance to
Farmers
um
and also clean energy New Hampshire uh
and New Hampshire saves we're also
um
avenues that might uh be useful in in
terms of
um
in terms of uh finding out in in terms
of sources of energy assistance for
Farmers
um and then
um I also spoke with so I spoke with
um
uh
uh with Elizabeth McKenna and she gave
me a little bit more detail about the
um what the USDA has uh and that's the
which is also something that was
mentioned uh in our
previous hearing which is the uh the
reap program
um
which is re uh rural energy assistance
program I think is the that's what it
stands for that again rural rural energy
assistance program thank you I think
that's the ACT what it stands for but
I'm not gonna you know I'm not gonna
um swear to it
um and that's uh run out of the
um USD USDA Rural Development Office in
Vermont uh and the contact person there
is Sarah Waring uh
and
um
the we also had some uh some input from
uh or some additional information from
uh
Tara Assad from the from the Council of
state governments CSG uh and uh so she
had she followed up a little bit with
the rural development office and uh the
application process for those reap loans
seems to be fairly complicated uh it's
the sort of thing that if you have a a
medium or well what is officially called
a small business which means up to 50
like 50 million dollars then
you you know if you if you are not at
the small end of a small bit of that
small business Spectrum then you
probably have someone on staff who can
go through all this stuff and figure out
how to fill out all the forms and
everything if you're a farmer it looks
like it's going to be tough
um so
um
so uh that's
but but that money is there there is
with the um Ira there is
um
the substantially more money has been
put into that so uh that is some that is
a
um
that is a
source of money that should be available
to us but I think that we need to have a
way to help farmers get that you know to
figure out how to get it
um another
um
another program or on
another program in the state which is a
non-gov non-governmental program is
through clean energy New Hampshire it's
primarily at this point for small
businesses I have not done further
research on that this but it's um the
circuit writer program uh and they work
with towns and small businesses to help
access and
um renewable energy
um
and uh so the
one of the things that came up uh in
many of these conversations was uh
Cooperative Extension as a as a
potential way to help
um and so I had
um
I the current state of things there is
that
um John Porter who is retired uh
extension faculty who is still working
part-time with them uh helping mostly
with engineering Dairy engineering Farms
on programs on farms has done some
assistance with solar with helping Farms
get solar as well but uh he is part-time
he is retired it's not he doesn't have
the capacity to do it on a scale that
um I uh so I had invited Ken Lavallee to
come in today Kendallville Valley is the
director of Co-op extension and uh
to help us figure out what we would need
to do in order to uh develop a line in
Co-op extension for uh uh for doing this
for
um
helping farmers get re renewable energy
um and
uh so uh
since he's not feeling well he he's not
here I was really hoping he could give
us some advice on
how we would what we would need to do to
juggle the
um
the way that monetary lines work in the
state in coordination with uh
Cooperative Extension uh because often
I'm not sure if that's administered
whether the chain of
um funding is from the state to the
university to Cooperative Extension or
if there's a direct
uh funding uh channel from the state to
Cooperative Extension uh and uh so
uh what I'm gonna have what I'll do is
I'll
touch base with him tomorrow and let me
see if I can get more information about
how that whole funding process works uh
but
um
I don't but uh
I think that uh
there are a lot of good reasons to see
if we can get a point person in
Cooperative Extension to help with
energy programs on farms because
for one thing uh farmers
are generally pretty comfortable talking
with Cooperative Extension uh not
necessarily so much with other branches
of government
um
and and so
and uh and Cooperative Extension has you
know you know really earned their trust
by being a very good technical resource
over a broad range of areas from you
know specific agricultural things to
helping out with
um mental health issues to helping out
with reducing you know things that will
reduce stress on Farmers by helping them
out helping them
uh get resources for financial planning
and business planning uh so there's uh I
think that
um
that
that's probably our best Avenue but we
need to figure out how to you know how
to do that and whether that requires
uh legislative action on our part or
whether it's something where we need to
intercede with the finance finance
committee to help them uh fund it get
more funding uh and I really don't know
how that works so I don't you have you
done some work with Finance Judy
oh limited work and
if if we and that would turn this into
an early bill that we would have to get
out right away to finance if if we made
any kind of amendment that made an
appropriation
so and I don't know that we'd be able to
do that at this point I mean
um
just in this discussion I mean
seems to me that there's a lot of
players involved and I One
one group you didn't mention was the
nrcf you know national resources
I should have mentioned them too okay
because they are well up in our in our
neck of the woods in our County
um they work extensively uh with the
Farm Bureau do you need your microphone
I'm sorry
thanks so they work extensively uh with
the Farm Bureau
um and um
the County Conservation uh Donald County
Conservation group to get
um equipment for Farmers that they can
rent I mean they just purchased last
year through a grant
um a no-till sea drill that any farmer
can rent we're all excited we're all
going to be fighting to rent it
um and then this year they've got
another Grant to purchase something but
they are really good at getting grants
for farmers and assisting them and I
think that
instead of having
the government us legislate anything if
we could get the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau UNH and them talking I think that
so the way oh okay go ahead so the way
I'm looking at this is the bill that is
in front of us now is is not
um
is not right and not what we would want
to pass because we don't want to give
this
um
uh task to Department of Agriculture and
there's other parts of it that are not
really helpful so
if we were to do anything to amend this
um I think it would be we would have to
write up pretty much a whole brand new
bill
yeah
okay okay
um I don't think that this bill is ready
for prime time in any manner
um personally I think that because of
the discussion with this bill we've
already got the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau talking Trevor who is the one
from Brookdale Farm that brought it to
uh the rep McGee's attention is a huge
part of New Hampshire Farm Bureau and I
know that on the policy we had a meeting
I wasn't on the Monday morning meeting
but we went over a lot of stuff and this
was brought up so they're going to be
talking about starting up their energy
subcommittee again I mean so I think we
need to
let the players
get involved and we have all these
organizations for a reason in the state
yeah it's very possible they may be able
to come up with a program on their own
so
um the one thing I was thinking in terms
of
um
extension is that it's it is one of the
places that a lot of people look for for
advice and uh that
um there are
um it sounds like the application
process is sufficiently complicated that
it would be very useful to have someone
have have a single person in the state
who really really knows how that process
works to be able to provide the
assistance
um and I agree that the bill as
presented to us uh will not achieve what
is will not get to get us to where we
want to be which is getting uh getting
energy assistance to Farmers uh which
where for which the money is out there
at the federal level there are also
programs that the in um like New
Hampshire saves at the state level uh
that or the which is not not strictly
which is also a part uh somewhat you
know public-private type of program
um and
uh helping uh Farmers figure out which
programs they need to go to how to get
the application that's going to require
someone who actually knows what's out
there uh and as opposed to doing as
opposed to having a committee and the
bill proposes a committee and it's just
a people a bunch of high-level people
talking in a room and not actually
mm-hmm
well would it be
I'm sorry representative Howard thank
you
um I agree that the committee doesn't
seem like a good solution it seems like
a parking lot to me and um and and it's
made up of people who are are sort of
who might be in the habit of parking
things what I wonder is
some of them anyway but um what I wonder
is if there isn't a way to
um create a
to get the funding into the state and
then and then create a a pool from which
they can draw it could we there's no way
so uh the way that the federal
legislation is written uh the for the
for the reap program which is the one
that would be the most uh the the most
neatly matched uh that is uh direct that
those grants go directly from the
federal government to the farmer or
business uh there is no State
involvement in that uh so what we're not
what we're
uh we're not looking to have a state
administered program because that's
going to cost actually more we're we're
looking at figuring out a way to get
um a you know a person who can provide
assistance uh and I so okay
um so it seems like maybe if we just
reconfigure the list of people who are
on this task force
um to include the co-op the cooperative
and and perhaps ncrs nrcs or New
Hampshire Farm Bureau can we be that
specific
uh I think we're I think that
let's go back to your parking lot
analogy
uh even if you put a couple of people
who actually know how to park cars in
the parking lot they're still parking
cars
uh they so
um the the real question is that I see
is uh is this something that
where well I think the first thing is
the bill as written with a task force
just won't work uh and we we I think we
probably have a pretty strong agreement
on that point uh so but the goal of the
bill which is to get energy assistance
to Farmers who could really use it uh
is a laudable goal and so the question
is do we need legislation to be able to
do that uh or is there or or do we need
legislation from this committee to do
that uh and
uh I without
um Cooperative Extension the room giving
us advice on what their mechanisms are I
don't think we can do that we won't we
won't know that
um I suspect that probably the best
uh way to go about this is
uh for me to discuss with Kendall Valley
what the process is and if that process
is extension specifically asking for
more money from uh in the budget process
for this targeted position then that is
something that extension would have to
do or that would have to go you know
from extension to the university and
then to the budget committee but it's
not but that's and and we could as a
committee potentially write a letter of
support uh if everyone on the committee
agrees but we would not uh we would not
be doing the legislation uh and so I my
my feeling at this point is uh be
uh our best action on this bill is
probably to retain it in case there's
some it turns out there's something we
can do with it but I don't think that we
can do what we knew I don't think that
uh
we can do something in this bill on the
time scale it takes to get it into the
budget process uh as you with our acting
as a committee
um
yeah because if we were to if we were to
amend this bill to purely be some sort
of appropriation
for UNH extension
that would have to be out by
February 16th right in order to get to
finance and we don't have enough time to
we don't have time to do that yeah
yeah
I agree with Peter I mean if if it's my
my things would be ital it or retain it
um
representative Howard
um I I agree in principle um when you
say a position at the co-op is is that
when you talk to Kendall Valley are you
did you say a position or just a
suggestion that they advise us
uh so
um when I talked with him before he said
that in order to be able to do this they
would need to have uh another they would
need to have another either position or
have to I don't remember exactly I don't
know that he's done the research on how
much
um labor he would need in order to do it
but he said that he did not have
currently have the capacity with his
current staff to just start this program
without
um uh with without a little without some
more staff assistance and
um the impression I got was that it um
would be
one person uh I'm not sure where there
would be you know one person or a
halftime person
um but uh
but that's uh he said that there would
need to be
um more more support and to extension
um this is just a question so
um I know that uh the person that I was
talking about with our grants for our
county is on the New Hampshire State
conservation committee
I'm on the governor's task force for the
Humane treatment of animals there's a
lot of committees out there already
established with the state is there
anything that focuses on this particular
uh I the information I got is that there
are
um a
some organizations that are doing things
that are kind of related but there's not
um there's not anything uh that is
focused directly on this uh and uh I
have not touched base with clean energy
New Hampshire to find out how the
circuit Rider program works that's uh
that is uh another possible Avenue
um
and uh it might another possible uh
Avenue would be if the Farm Bureau gets
their energy uh committee together they
may be able to uh direct be able to
direct Farmers to a range of resources
that are available
um and
what what I'm concerned about is I don't
want our Farmers to miss out on things
because they look at the application
process first of all they have to figure
out where the application process is
because it you know there's no
centralized
piece of source of where that of that
information and then once they find
something they might be able to apply
for they look at it and they say oh I
need this Federal Form that Federal
Federal Form and that Federal Form and I
don't know how to fill them out and I
don't have time to fill them out because
my uh I need to fix my tractor I need to
you know find a new and a digital source
of feed for my animals
et cetera et cetera et cetera I mean
there are
um it's it's the sort of thing where
doing government paperwork is may have a
long-term benefit but it's not going to
deal with what needs to happen
immediately on the farm and
uh so uh it seems like they're like
having some mechanism for
assisting Farmers with filling it out uh
would be highly beneficial uh and uh I
know that
so that you uh extension does some level
of assistance in terms of other business
operations uh
to uh in terms of uh
figuring out uh long-term planning
figuring out uh you know how to use a
spreadsheet to uh you know sort out your
resources and finances and whatnot uh
and it seems like it it might be this
this would be kind of in line with that
sort of help
um
I wonder if
um representative vos's energy committee
has any Finance any bills going to
finance that he could tack on
um that's being amended anyway that he
could tack on some sort of
appropriation for UNH extension for
energy relief for Farmers
um okay
I think it's a little premature for us
to be talking about putting an
appropriation in right now
um only because
um I think there's a lot of other viable
options out there
um with like the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau the national resources
um and you know if we can get these
groups talking to each other I mean
why not try that Avenue first yeah yeah
so would it be worthwhile maybe for our
committee to draft some sort of letter
to these different organizations asking
them to collaborate with one another on
this issue
um that seems like a good a reasonable
possibility I I I'm also going to follow
up with Kendall Valley because if it's
something where he can put in a request
without going through us then that would
be
um I mean
there's then we would that wouldn't
require our action on our absolutely
yeah and so but I think that if there is
going to be an appropriation request uh
during this cycle that it's going to
have to come from uh from extension
without our intervention and I don't
think that trying to put it through the
energy committee would be any better
than trying to put it through us it's
got to be they make them making the ass
I don't know how much information this
will helpful information this will be
but we're having solar put on our house
and I spoke to the consultant and
um I think when the people came in for
the hearing they were talking about
Kimball Farm down in Massachusetts
he said that that was a special project
that was done years ago and it was a
different setup and so when they you
can't compare Kimball to what's
happening in New Hampshire it's it's
separate it was done almost 20 years ago
and they really put a lot into it
because it was an experiment and he said
that uh
um that was his understanding because
he's been in the industry so anyway
um in case there was a comparison like
why aren't the New Hampshire Farmers
getting this it was because he said it
was a different program
yeah representative yeah so that that
makes sense I mean Massachusetts has a
different way of
um doing their energy support for solar
energy and renewable energy uh a fairly
a fairly more aggressive than than New
Hampshire and uh so
um I don't it's
um
so I I don't think that Kimball Farm is
actually any sort of model for what we
would want to do here uh it's uh we're
looking more at you know there are we
know there are now federal funds out
there we want
our Farmers to be able to take advantage
of that there are certain
um red tape hurdles that it would be
rather than having a uh 50 million
dollar small business that happens to be
uh in a rural part of New England
getting the the large chunk of that
money we would like to see that money
going to a number of small farms in New
Hampshire so uh so uh and but our small
farms don't have the red tape cutting
ability that a bigger business does uh
so uh we want so figuring out avenues
for for cutting that red tape and I
think probably a combination of what rep
Compton is saying about getting the Farm
Bureau the Farmers Union nrcs
Etc involved and
um
seeing if Co-op extension can help out
as well probably is our best bet and I I
like uh chairman Aaron's idea of writing
a letter to the various organizations
saying this is something that's on our
radar is there a way that you guys can
get together and collaborate on this to
make it work better
yeah
okay so any other comments about this um
because I think that's probably the way
to go and
um
I don't know if
you and I can draft up something if you
want to do that
yes that makes sense and um I I guess on
I was looking on the Dateline and plans
of when we were going to hear bills and
when we were going to exec bills and I
guess this bill would end up getting
exact on um somewhere February 28th ish
so um you know we have time because it's
not an early bill we have time to think
about whether we want itl or retain but
in the meantime we can draft up a letter
anything further on this I guess we
unless
we have anything further then I think we
are we all set
yeah okay
well I guess uh
no go ahead no this is something
different to adjourn oh all right so
I'll I'll adjourn the the subcommittee
work session on HB 369
thank you
any substitutes today we do not
everyone's going to be here as I know
yes
all right
um so I know we the agricultural
subcommittee I know that there was some
talk between you and I about
[Music]
um
uh next week is 2 7 is it not yeah yeah
okay
so uh
let's see uh hb221 is the bill relative
to the acquisition of agricultural land
development rights
and
I just wanted to double check make sure
that's not an early bill it's not so
that's not an early bill either
um and
I think it we could get together at 9 00
A.M
next week
and talk about hb221 it's a we have it
on the docket today for the exec session
but I guess you were going to make
representative Bixby was going to make a
motion to defer it to a subcommittee and
not exec it out today yeah
I know that I'm pretty sure
I've seen that done before so I know
that there's got to be well there's been
new information so um I think it makes
sense if there's new information and
it's not an early bill it's not critical
to
so would we retain it I think today I
think no I think it's we refer to
commitments let me go ask yeah
okay
um all right so
so and I can
morning everybody Welcome to environment
agriculture committee uh we are going to
open up our exec session with a pledge
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
foreign
clerk would you please roll call the
roll
thank you madam chair
Aaron here
representative Creighton here
representative here representative
verville
here representative Davis representative
brouillon here representative Coolin
represent Kenny represent Potenza
here representative smart
represent Bixby here representative
representative dutse representative
Murray
representative jomana here
representative Haskins
representative Howard representative NAB
representative Morse
and representative Voigt here
everyone is here Madam chair thank you
very much
I'm going to open up the exact session
on HB 79
and I would like to hear a motion
representative Bixby
I move ought to pass on HB 79 and I'll
be presenting an amendment
we're here a second
my second ma'am representative Creighton
seconds
any discussion
uh
so would you like to explain your motion
I mean right so um
so the bill as it was presented to us uh
was uh
there was a number of a lot of testimony
indicating that it was not really
workable but uh one of the key points
that came out of that was that there are
many
um
many many issues with uh the uh chapter
RSA 4034 that may be out of date now
that we a lot of that is that material
is governed by the um this month uh food
safety monitors modernization act uh and
uh so uh the idea came up that we could
uh reduce a number of
um regulations that are outdated uh and
uh in chapter 434 by doing by doing a
study committee on that and identifying
problems with that chapter it also came
up that for a lot of the
um that fisma is currently
um
uh administered under the um
under RSA 426 which also does a certain
amount of regulation of uh standards for
food products uh and Mar and farm
products uh and uh grading so
um
I added to the study committee in my
Amendment uh RSA 426 so what the study
committee would do
um and I should probably just
um move on to moving the amendment
and uh oh and pass out the amendment yes
so we have an amendment
uh and if I didn't
get I
if if the balance come out you know if
the ballot if they're enough if the
balance doesn't come out then just
please bring the rest over to the other
side
we don't have a printout
yeah
all right so at this point I'd like to
move uh unless there's further
discussion on on the underlying Bill I'd
like to move Amendment hb79
um
amendment is zero two one two H yes so
okay
and we have a second
Madam chair I second the most
so
um what uh what this bill does what the
the amendment does is it replaces the
entire bill with a bill creating a study
committee and the study committee uh
study committee to study laws relative
to standards from our farm products and
marketing and Grading Commodities uh it
will the committee will have three mem
four members three members from the
house appointed by the speaker and one
member from the Senate uh and uh the
duties of the committee which is the the
core of this bill is uh the committee
shall review
RSA 426 and RSA 434 and assess are the
statutes consistent with current
regulatory needs and practices are there
overlapping redundant or conflicting
statutes in RSA 426 and 434 and do any
statutes need to be transferred from one
chapter to the other to provide Clarity
and consistency and then the rest of it
is the how the committee gets put
together initially and
um when the report needs to come out
which is
um
and by November 1st of 2023
okay thank you is there any further
discussion
seeing none I'd like to take a ask the
clerk to take a roll call vote for this
amendment
yes we are voting on the adoption of
20230212h on HB 79 representative
Creighton
Creighton votes yes representative yes
representative verville yes
representative Davis yeah representative
brilliard yes everything cool on yes
represent Kenny represent Potenza
yes representative smart
yes represent Bixby yes representative
represent dutse yes representative
Murray yeah yeah represent germana yes
representative Haskins yes
representative Howard yes representative
NAB representative Morse someone vote
20 20 zero motion the amendment is
adopted wonderful
and do I hear a motion to uh for otpa on
this bill HB yes 79
um I will move uh
otpa with Amendment uh
and do I hear a second
seeing none
um
Madam clerk would you call the roll
thank you madam chair we are voting on
HB 79 with an otpa
uh representative Creighton Creighton
votes yes representative yes
representative verville yes represent
Davis represent burliad yes represent
cooling represent Kenny represent
Potenza yes represent smart yes
represent Bixby yes representative
represent dutse yes represent Murray
representative Haskins yes
representative jamana yes represent
Howard yes represent NAB represent Morse
and then vote Yes Madam chair chair
votes yes 20-0 motion passes thank you
uh Madam chair
we need to put in who is going to be
writing the uh committee report please
and do we want this on consent the
committee report I believe would be
written by representative Bixby
and uh would anybody object for this
being put on consent calendar
seeing none
I close the exec on HB 79 and we move
over to hb128 relative to repealing
State seed labeling license requirements
do I hear a motion on that
representative Crichton Madam chair I
make a motion to itl hb128
do I hear a second Madam chair I second
the motion thank you
would you like to speak to your motion
representative Creighton
uh yes ma'am the bottom line is on 128
that we were presenting a lot of
different facts but
um there was no compelling testimony as
to the requirement for this bill and so
I think that uh we've got a bill that's
looking for a solution
thank you is there any further
discussion on this bill representative
Bixby yes so um
back in 20
I believe it's 2014 or 15. 2014
um the there was a um the exemption was
brought to us as a bill and at that
point
um before then you needed to seed
license no matter how few C2 were
selling and uh the committee felt that
it was
um that if someone wanted to be able to
sell a few seeds uh for their own
um stock their own uh saved seeds at a
farmer's market or something they
shouldn't have to go be able to have to
go through the entire seed licensing
process but that this should be
basically available for on a just a very
small uh small basis because uh in order
to uh in order to have a clear uh and
safe supply of seeds for larger growers
in the state
um so essentially Farmers uh the uh the
the seed inspection process really
needed to stay in place and we debated
for a long time what was the maximum
number of seeds that you would be able
that you should
be able to sell and initially we're
thinking it should be on the order of
maybe a pound or two because you know a
pound of tomato seeds this is an awful
lot of tomato plants and then someone
brought up well what about corn and
beans because
um those are those seeds are heavier and
we thought okay we're just going to put
it at the highest conceivable limit that
anyone would possibly use if they were
are going to be doing this uh just like
farmers markets and that sort of thing
and farm stands and we said okay 25
pounds is more than anyone is going to
be selling
under that basis and I would still and
we did not hear anyone come to our
commit to the Committee hearing saying
that the 25 pound limit was in any way a
problem so uh I would uh concur with
representative Creighton's assessment
that this is a um a solution seeking a
problem
thank you representative Bixby any other
discussion
seeing none I would ask the clerk to
have a roll call thank you madam chair
we are voting itl on HB
128--fn representative Creighton
Creighton votes yay representative yes
representative verville yes
representative Davis yes represent
brilliard yes representative coulin
represent Kenny represent Potenza yes
represent smart
represent Bixby yes representative
represent dutse representative Murray
yes representative jamana yes
representative Haskins yes
representative Howard yes representative
NAB represent Morse representative yes
Madam chair chair votes yes 20-0 motion
passes thank you I'll close the exec on
128. excuse me Madam chair oh I'm sorry
yes uh do you want this on consent uh
is it okay for it to be on consent
see no objection yes let's put it on
consent
thank you
and representative Creighton will be
the second one you could do one or the
other I gave you a duplicate noise okay
sorry
um so I close uh one
um the execon 128 and open uh the exact
hearing on HB 138 relative to oversight
of the commissioner of Department of
Agriculture markets and food
and do I hear um a motion for that
representative Howard I move out to pass
on HB 138
okay and
okay representative Howard would you
like to speak to your
um
to your motion given that the uh the
clerical position relative to assisting
the veteran Veterinary examiners is
already
um been they have already closed that
down and the provisions relative to the
contagious equine matritis has also been
discontinued the provisions are no
longer needed
thank you
any discussion on this motion
seeing none I direct the clerk to call
the roll on this
thank you madam chair hb138 OTP
represent Creighton Creighton votes yay
representative
yes representative
Reverend that verville Reverend Davis
representative brilliard yes Rose and
coulin yes represent Kenny represent
Potenza
yes representative smart represent Bixby
yes representative
representative dutzie represent Murray
yeah representative
yes representative Haskins yes represent
Howard yes represent NAB represent Morse
representative yes Madam chair chair
votes yes 20-0 do we want this on
consent
any objection to it being on the consent
calendar
nope seeing none let's put it on consent
and representative Howard we'll be doing
okay so I close the exec on HB 138 and
open the exec on 150 HB 152
do I hear a motion on hb152
Madam chair I have a motion
representative germana uh I move ought
to pass on HB 152.
do I hear a second
thank you representative smart
representative germano would you like to
speak to your emotion please thank you
madam chair uh this bill provides some
statutory definition for soil additives
which is consistent with the chapter in
which it is contained uh and if I may
I'd like to refer to representative
Bixby to explain some of the changes
around uh the definition for inspection
fees and appropriate penalties
yes representative Bixby
so um the uh
some this is essentially this is this
makes a number of of small changes to
um to clear up uh things in this chapter
that were outdated uh one of them was
the amount of the
um the penalty if uh a seller of
fertilizer did not uh file a report and
that penalty was previously uh
insufficient to actually provide any
incentive and this bill allows the
commissioner to uh set that fee in that
penalty and rules
um
and it also uh changes previously uh if
a if someone were shorted on their
fertilizer if the quality of the
fertilizer was deficient uh you had to
be buying at least a ton of the
fertilizer to get a refund on that uh
through through the penalty payment and
now this mean this says that anybody
that is sold uh deficient fertilizer can
get the refund
and
it also changes the way that uh the
value of fertilizer is calculated by
simply looking at the invoiced price
rather than doing a survey of all the
fertilizer producers out there and uh it
also uh removes removes
um a
an exemption for
um selling fertilizers at retail that
those for those uh Exempted fertilizers
should by nearly a decade later should
already have been uh sold out so that
exemption is no longer needed
thank you representative Bixby any other
seeing none I am directing Madam chair
uh Madam clerk to recall a role oh dear
thank you madam chair thank you this is
OTP on HB 152. represent Creighton
Creighton votes yay representative yes
representative verville yes
representative Davis represent burliad
yes represent coulin yes yes represent
Kenny represent Potenza yes
representative smart represent Bixby yes
representative
representative yes represent Murray yes
yes representative yes representative
Haskins yes representative Howard yes
representative NAB represent Morse
representative yes Madam chair Madam
chair votes yes 20-0 do we want this on
consent thank you uh any objection to be
um
and this goes to representative germana
thank you madam chair
and um I will close the hearing on
hb152.
um I will open up the exec on HB 221
and I want to advise the committee that
we will not be executing this bill we
are instead going to be
um
executing this bill on February 7th so
I'm going to recess this
until February 7th there's been some new
information that's come to us and so
um
we will be recessing this uh this exec
okay uh represented yeah representative
Bixby do you also want to make a note
that we're going to be doing a
subcommittee
um uh yes yes yes uh I have
um we'll make arrangements for February
7th at 9 A.M
to have a ag
agriculture policy committee
okay
now I will open up the exact session on
HB 252
and I'm passing around an amendment
do I hear a motion for this
representative control thank you madam
chair I would like to move for the
20230186h4hb 252.
okay well uh first we have to say that
um we we want to
the motion is for ought to pass but
you're presenting an amendment
correct
first and then
okay
um okay so we have a motion to uh
and representative Bixby seconds would
you like to speak to your Amendment
please represent control thank you madam
chair uh this amendment just affixed a
clerical era in the original Amendment
and changed word said amend RSA 47 to
RSA 47 colon 17 to make it short was
being appropriated to the correct
section of that RSA
it's just a clerical
thank you the amendment number is
2023-0186h
okay
Madam uh clerk would you like to take a
roll call on this amendment
thank you madam chair uh this is for the
20230186h representative Creighton
Creighton volcier president yes
representative verville yes
representative Davis represent brilliard
yes represent coulin represent Kenny
represent Potenza
yes representative smart
represent Bixby representative represent
dutse yes representative Murray yes
representative yes represent Haskins yes
represent Howard represent NAB represent
Morse or is him Voigt yes Madam chair
chair votes yes
amendment is adopted 20-0 thank you and
right
correct right
I will make a motion
I'll second that motion
any discussion would you like to speak
to your motion
uh Madam chair thank you very much
um the reason this was brought forth
that I think was very uh simple is that
noise ordinances are going in at the
local levels
um
and people are not understanding what
agricultural purposes are and don't
understand the complexities and the
times when people in agriculture
actually have to be out doing their jobs
um
if you have a tree fall on your fence at
3am in the morning you need to go out
there and start that chainsaw and that
would be in violation of a noise
ordinance if you have to start up a
tractor at one o'clock in the morning to
pull out a calf that would be in
violation of a noise ordinance
what this bill does is exempt those
practices so that there will be no
question that they are actually legal
activities and the farmers will not be
stressed out
um regarding these practices
any further discussion point of order
Madam chair yes uh it was my
understanding that there was going to be
a second amendment to this bill is that
incorrect
I there has no not been another
amendment presented
okay
uh representative Bixby so one uh one
aspect of this that came up during our
uh discussion after that came up in the
hearing and then in our discussion after
the hearing was uh What uh what about
agritourism and uh would it be a would
the fact that this basically this bill
this um bill as written and as um with
this minor uh clerical correction uh
that it would allow
um Farms to be exempt both uh including
their agritourism operations and if a
farm uh we're carrying were now I had uh
doing weddings or uh some some events
like that as part of their
um
operation and uh though and uh that
ended up creating like you know bands or
whatever at the event venue that could
uh that would not the municipalities
would not be able to say well there's a
certain hour Beyond which you can't have
that sort of event or that kind of that
kind that uh
that that aspect of agritourism making
that kind of noise uh and that uh was
seen by by a number of people as a
problem with this bill I believe that
there is an amendment available to
address that problem uh and uh so I
would be in favor of this bill if it uh
if it didn't uh if there could be that
exempt
removal of the exemption for specific
specifically for agritourism I will have
difficulty with the bill if that
exemption if that if agrotourism is
still included
I'm sure representative thank you madam
chair and yes there was another
amendment uh prepared
um however when reading further
information that I was given
and understanding what agritourism is if
you remove agritourism from this bill
you are saying to Farmers who have corn
mazes or do hayrides or have any special
events on their farms in the evening
that they are not Exempted from a noise
ordinance I mean I know that we're
focusing on weddings only in bands but
the majority of agritourism in the state
is not weddings and bands it is haunted
hayrides it could be corn mazes it could
be a fundraiser for local uh food bank
we don't know there are a lot of
activities that go on it could be a
Moonlight walk on your farm and that
people might be having a good time in
around a campfire and that they would no
longer be able to do that if a noise
ordinance might be enforced
so
to exempt agritourism in its total I
think would be a disservice and be
harmful to Farms
representative datsey
okay uh am I correct that local
ordinances would cover local farms and
that local communities still are uh
assuming that this law does not pass at
the present time local communities are
able to regulate noise ordinances in
farming communities so that they can
meet the needs of their communities is
that correct
representative kantois that is correct
however with the increase of people I
know in my town where we are seeing an
influx of people coming in to retire
uh they don't want to be disturbed
before a certain hour or disturbed after
a certain hour during the day
um they actually tried to put in a very
Draconian noise ordinance
which would have been detrimental to
every farmer in my town that I live in
we have over 10 Farms just in the small
town that I live in and to
cause them more stress in any added
degree of worrying about what they do
and not do
is is harmful and all we're asking for
uh representative verbal thank you madam
chair so
I have to confess I I believe that the
agritourism should also be exempt the
New Hampshire farmers are not getting
rich they're not getting rich fast and
they need every source of income that
they can that they can come up with
we always talk about how much we value
agriculture in the state we always hear
testimony about how much people like the
the open space and and the open land and
those benefits I agree they're they're
real
and if we're going to protect them we
have to make sure that that people have
multiple means of earning a living
some years of farming are very good some
years of farming are very very lean and
to offset marginal years or years of
losses allowing people to do other
things with with property with their
private property is in the best interest
of the of the State of New Hampshire in
my belief and so uh while I well I
appreciate some of the concerns that
have been brought forth
I'll support I'll support the bill is
currently amended I would have trouble
supporting the bill if it was to carve
out agritourism as being subject to
local noise ordinance thank you madam
chair thank you representative
representative Dotsy
uh yes
um
I respect the comments made by
representative verbal and representative
and I and I understand that but I
believe in in past sessions we've had
difficulty with the definition of
Agriculture and one of my concerns would
be that you get a let's say a neighbor
who has a couple of acres of land and a
tractor and decides that he's having a
feud with another neighbor
and fires up his tractor at three in the
morning and
um Can disrupt the whole area just based
not based on agriculture but based on
possibly a neighborhood Feud and my
concern is I apologize for not being
able to be at the public hearing but are
there any
things in place so that something like
this can be addressed and a farmer
cannot use this ordinance to aggravate
other neighbors
representative come to our
um
chapter
RSA
2134-a defines what agriculture is it's
very specific but it is Broad in
Spectrum at times
so I'll just leave it at that but if you
representative Howard
I I wonder if um
if we were to uh exclude the agritourism
from the um from the this bill from from
the exemptions don't we return the power
to to Grant people like
um permission
to the municipalities couldn't they if
you were planning to have an event or or
if you do hayrides over the course of
the fall or something like that couldn't
you apply to your municipality and that
and that way
it's the path is sort of smooth for you
representative
uh thank you
um Madam chair
um we had a problem with the noise
ordinance because of a rooster How
likely do you think that town is going
to allow someone to have anything after
Madam chair
representative vervo thank you madam
chair if I may and and I I appreciate
the point I I certainly do
when I read this amendment
this amendment in my view allows a
community to essentially shut down
agritourism based on noise ordinance so
it it actually has the potential
to zone out a business
that's antithetical to the New Hampshire
way
I I don't disagree that the hypothetical
could come true
but I don't see that as a widespread
problem
further if there is sort of this grudge
match between Neighbors which
unfortunately does occur
um if if firing up the tractor on the
property line at odd hours isn't allowed
they will find some other way to be
grudged their their neighbors we're
talking about potentially shutting down
an industry for the potentiality of a
grudge match between neighbors occurring
and for me that is not a sound reason to
set uh such a strict uh State policy and
and for that reason this amendment gives
me great concern thank you madam chair
representative Knapp
thank you madam chair I can only speak
to what happens in our town but we do
have a farm that holds weddings and they
have an exemption to do several a year
but this completely takes the recourse
away from the town and tries to mitigate
that situation and a farm having a
wedding it's agrotourism but it is a
it's a really big event and it's a
really big impact on the Butters and I
think not having that exemption is
really problematic I think
representative dutsy also spoke to the
fact that I think this bill entirely is
too broad because the definition of
farming is so broad that anyone who has
one rooster or anyone who has one raised
bed is essentially a Farm by definition
and so I think this bill essentially
cripples towns from having any sort of
noise ordinance anyone could say I grow
pumpkins in my backyard so therefore I
can do anything any hour of the day so I
appreciate the spirit of the bill
because we have so many farms in my town
and I do want to support them but I
think as it's written it's overly broad
I think not having an exemption for
agritourism could be really disastrous
representative germana thank you madam
chair and I appreciate my colleague
represented uh ferval's reference to
kind of the New Hampshire way and it
puts me in the mind of a similar comment
that the governor made in his inaugural
address about the New Hampshire way
would I sometimes get confused about is
what local control means right if
there's an argument about we need to
have local control and resist for
example regulations at the level of the
federal government and yet in other
cases it's okay if that control is in
Concord and not in Keene or in Cheshire
county or in other of our local
communities so when we talk about what
local control means I'm concerned
because there's an inconsistency about
how we apply that term in this case I
think that giving localities the
opportunity to work through these issues
and make those decisions based upon the
input of their citizens uh is uh to my
mind a preferable example of the New
Hampshire way
representative Davis
yeah it just uh it leads me to wonder
what if why is this being talked about
just with agriculture like what if any
of us have a
have a wedding at our property have a
graduation party I mean we have the
ability to make the same noise without
it being Agriculture and uh
the farmers I think need all the help
they can get I I believe this is
sustaining a lot of the Farms so
uh I know that's a commercial end of it
it's not a private thing but there's
only so many weekends there's only so
many times this is going to be had in a
year
I I don't really feel like it's a place
to legislate that they cannot have these
functions
representative smart
I also thank you madam chair I also we
have a Airbnb up the road from us that's
also a working farm and
um
they hold weddings there there's been I
live in a very small community uh large
acreage wise but small people wise and
we've had people complain about
the noise from the bands and what we
have done as a community was go to the
people that are hosting it and just
saying at a certain time can we lower
the noise for the band
um just so that it's not reverberating
across a community so therefore they can
still have their venue they still but
we're handling it more as a community
than rather than a law
um being passed so it's more neighborly
which I think is the New Hampshire way
thank you for that any other questions
represent Bixby yes
um I think
um I I'd like to move uh Amendment uh HB
2023-0178h uh and which is the which
would remove the agritourism from the
exemption uh and uh we can then further
discuss whether or not uh we're going to
keep that in place or add that to the
bill
okay would you like to speak to that
motion representative Bixby yes so
um
I think that there is there's a
there's a combination of uh well I guess
one of the reasons that I uh think that
is important to have attach this
amendment is because this is an issue
that was raised uh to me and I think it
was also raised in the hearing by both
the Farm Bureau and by uh the by the
commissioner that uh that the uh not
having this uh exempt exemption for the
from the exemption for uh agritourism uh
could create uh further problems and
um I think that
um
and just taking on taking I I I value
the advice of the Farm Bureau I value
the advice of the commissioner and I
think that uh that the commissioner has
been Fielding a number of questions
related to agritourism and to uh the
boundaries of it and he's
familiar with enough with this that I
any other comment representative verbal
thank you madam chair and uh I I
I don't disagree I suppose in in
principle I guess my preference would be
that the state committee
take a reactive approach to potential
problems after they manifest themselves
rather than taking a proactive approach
and carving out certain types of
businesses on anecdotes of it being some
sort of serious problem in the state I
don't I don't believe it is a serious
problem in the state I think it's highly
unlikely to become a serious problem in
the state and so I would I would say
that we we should not pass this
amendment we should pass the bill as
we've previously amended it and then if
uh if a problem you know if people can
come forth and demonstrate that there is
an actual problem that would be a better
time for us to to legislate corrective
action so that would be my preference
and for that reason I think I'll be
voting against this amendment thank you
madam chair
representative verbal thank you for that
and I concur with your comments uh
representative
representative Howard
so it doesn't pertain to the noise issue
that we're talking about here but in my
town
um we do have some people who came into
the town and um bought a piece of
property and started calling themselves
a farm and you know did it clear did a
bunch of stuff without any permits from
the town and when they were called into
the town to to start to the process of
negotiating with the town for permitting
and they used the agriculture as a
defense against needing to check with
the town at all so I think that taking
um the power to to legislate important
things like what what you do like how
you use your land
um that that is harmful to the community
that that needs to stay in the hands of
the municipalities and not um and so I
think that by eliminating
the exemption from agritourism it gives
you the town a chance to um apply its
ordinances
seeing none representative comtwa ask
you to call the role thank you madam
chair we are voting on the amendment
Dash zero one seven H for HB 252
representative Creighton Creighton votes
nay Representative no Representative
verville no representative Davis
Representative brilliard no represent
coulin
represent Kenny represent Potenza no
represents smart
represent Bixby yeah representis
represent dutse yes represent Murray
representative yes represent Haskins yes
represent Howard yes
representative NAB represent Morse
represent Voigt yes
motion fails vote is nine yes 11 Nays
okay so that brings us back to uh
voting on uh HB 252 with the amendment
that previously passed do I hear motion
on that
Madam chair I'll make the motion to pass
representative verbal Madam chair I'll
second that motion
Madam clerk I'd like you to call the
roll on otpa for HB 252.
thank you madam chair we are voting on
HB
252 with Amendment 2023 Dash was zero
one eight six h
representative Creighton Creighton
Bertier represent yes representative
verbal yes representative Davis
representative bulliard yes represent
coulon represent Kenny represent Potenza
yes representative smart represent Bixby
representis represent dutse represent
Murray
no represent Haskins no represent Howard
represent NAB
represent Morse represent Voigt no Madam
12-8 motion passes
okay
um the question is does anyone want to
do a Minority Report
who
representative NAB will write The
Minority Report
and representative uh comma you will
vote uh you will write the majority
report
okay
close the exec on HB 252 and we move on
to HB 300
do I hear a motion for HB 300 Madam
chair I'd like to make a motion
what is your motion represent Murray uh
thank you I'd like to
just the amendment for I'd like to make
a motion of uh
uh yes if you submitted it
electronically I believe
I did send it out to everybody I don't
but basically
um
um Madam chair thank you very much so
basically the amendment uh just
um looks at the radius that we had
discussed instead of it being 50 miles
it was reduced down to 20 miles
um and so basically that would
um
just replace that language in that
respect it's just
shortening that um circumference
okay thank you anybody would anybody
else uh would like to speak to that
Amendment
uh so um
representative Bixby
yeah so uh what the so the
um excuse me one moment did we have a
second on that that was going to be my
point of water yeah I'm sorry we need a
second on the moment okay
um yeah I'll I'll I'll second that
um
okay so we now have a second and now I
can make a brief comment right right now
you can speak to your motion so uh the
original Bill had
um said that the radius that there had
to be an available uh processor for
um food waste uh uh in order for a uh an
organization or company or a business to
be governed by this could be 50 miles uh
and in in the hearing we heard that uh
neighboring states typically had 20
miles and we didn't feel that uh it was
necessary to be stricter than
neighboring states so uh we reduced it
to 20 miles
seeing none
uh representative comta would you take
the role thank you madam chair this is
2023-0169h representative Creighton
Creighton votes yay representative yes
representative yes representative Davis
represent brilliard yes president Coolin
yes I was in Kenny represent Potenza
yes we've been smart represent Bixby yes
represent suffocatus represent dutse
represent Murray yeah yeah
representative
yes represent Haskins yes president
Howard yeah represent more
yeah represent vote Yes Madam chair
Madam chair votes yes 20-0 amendment is
adopted
and do I hear a motion for otpa yes
Madam chair I'd like to speak to my
motion I have one oh well go ahead
and if I couldn't may I speak to my oh
that's right I can't sorry thank you
do I hear a second on that
okay
um
oh yeah yeah would you speak to that
motion I'm sorry thank you madam chair
I got lost no that's okay thank you so
HP 300 as amended would basically
um look to ban uh food waste generators
who produce more than a ton or more of
food waste from disposing that in
landfills and based on what we know has
come out of our Solid Waste uh working
groups these are recommendations that we
are working towards as a state
collectively that would also go towards
our waste disposal reduction goals and
so to that end I would urge
otpa thank you
any other discussion on this
representative Bixby yeah
yeah it's sort of to amplify that one of
um
one food waste going into landfills is
one of the
um greatest generators of uh of
off-gassing from a landfills is also
very heavy the the tonnage of of organic
waste going into landfills is
substantial uh it is something that is
um
uh that uh is doesn't really has other
use higher and better uses than going
into landfill uh so uh one of the things
that the bill does is it creates a set
of diversion goals so if the food waste
is wasted is actually uh viable for
being used to feed people who need the
food there are methods of subverting it
to
um
the food banks food pantries uh that is
a higher diversion method than uh and uh
that would count towards a thousand
pounds of diversion uh if it is uh
compostable then it can or it could be
used as animal feed those are also
viable methods of diversion so uh the
idea is that by using the hierarchy in
the Bill of diverting it to the best
uses uh we can get we can remove this
waste stream from the landfill the
reason for the thousand pounds is
because
uh the one oh sorry the one ton is that
um
being able to we need to uh jump start
an industry to be able to handle this
and by starting with large producers it
will make it easier for uh for
businesses to start up or to move into
the area that would be able to handle
that those larger more concentrated
amounts before figuring out how to deal
with picking up a few pounds here and
there from from a lot of residential
sources uh which is much more
challenging logistically than on picking
up from concentrated sources so a
secondary effect of this bill should be
that it will generate businesses in New
Hampshire that will be able to handle
this waste
thank you representative Bixby
representative Murray thank you in
addition to that um there are goals that
both the working group and the
celebration management plan have worked
towards and one of those is also to work
towards
um industry supporting industry uh
Solutions and so I think that this bill
also supports those goals within those
working groups as well thank you any
other comments representative jamona
thank you madam chair I'd like to speak
in favor of the bill I recently attended
a city council meeting in Keene where
there was a presentation by the
assistant director of the landfill in
Keene uh and he was talking to the the
council about how we're running out of
space in our landfill this is a serious
issue we're going to have to start
considering and I know that Keen is not
going to be alone in that so as much
food waste as we can divert uh will be
extremely helpful in in terms of using
uh that space wisely and I also wanted
to speak also briefly to a point that
representative Bixby made about the
opportunities this creates for
businesses to begin to fill this Niche
we've got a great startup business in
Keene Elm City compost initiative and
that's been growing uh you know working
with residents I used her services and
they're fantastic you can drop them off
at the the co-op they have a place where
you can drop it off or there is there's
curbside pickup as well so I also see
this as a as a great opportunity to
stimulate some small businesses who can
move into this Niche and take advantage
of of the program thank you madam chair
thank you any other comment
seeing none I'd like to direct the clerk
for a roll call thank you madam chair
we're voting on otpa for HB 300--fn
what's the amendment
20230169h representative Creighton
Creighton votes yay represent come to
our yes representative verville yes
representative Davis represent brilliard
yes or the coolant President Kenny
representative tenza yes from the smart
represent Bixby yeah represents off
akitis
represent dutse yes represent Murray
representative jomana yes Ben Haskins
yes Howard Robertson NAB represent Morse
yeah president Voigt yes Madam chair
Madam chair votes yes motion passes
20-0.
thank you
um
that can't go on consent because it is
uh
yeah it's got too much money attached to
it
okay
so I'm going to close the exec on HB 300
and open the exec on HB 462.
and I would like to make a Motion
Auto pass and I'm with an amendment
adapt to adopt an amendment
the amendment to this bill is
um from representative evil is
2023-05.0159h
and her Amendment clears up the language
oh I'm do I hear a second by the way
yes you got it
okay
so I'd like to speak to my Amendment uh
here the amendment that was presented uh
this amendment clears up the language
uh which is in the bill uh regarding
uh extra sources of income to this fund
um the fund is is the solid waste
management fund
and
um so the wording includes United States
environment Protection Agency and other
federal agencies gifts donations of
money grants legislative Appropriations
or any other matching funds in its
incentives so this is good because this
allows the fund to accept monies from
other places other than general fund
do I hear any further discussion on this
amendment
representative Bixby uh just to um the
the original version had a phrasing that
made it seem like all of the money had
to be coming from some sort of uh EPA or
federal Source uh in one reading of it
and what this amendment does is it just
uh makes the wording clear
thank you representative Bixby any
further discussion on this amendment
seeing none I direct the clerk to take a
roll call on the amendment adoption
thank you madam chair we're voting to
2023-0159h for Bill HB
462-fn-a representative Creighton
Creighton Gautier we're going to come to
our yes representative verbal yes
represent Davis represent burliard yes
represent cooling yes from Kenny from
Potenza yes from his smart represent
Bixby representative represent dutse
represent Murray or Mr jumana yes
representative Haskins yes
representative Howard represent NAB
represent Morse president Voigt yes
Madam chair Madam chair votes yes 20-0
the amendment is adopted
thank you
and I'd like to
um make a motion to pass HB 462
otpa with this amendment
that we just voted on do I hear a second
thank you representative
and I'll speak to this amendment uh I
mean to this bill with its Amendment
so we have a solid waste management fund
and we are looking to appropriate a sum
of two million dollars for fiscal year
ending June 30th 2023
um that way we can fund the efforts to
diversion programs where we would be
supporting efforts to promote
composting and
um
keeping food waste out of our landfills
and uh
that's all I'm going to say about that I
will be supporting it representative
Murray thank you madam chair I I too
concur with your statement I think that
this is a great first step to directing
some dedicated funding to an area that
we can use this for the sole purpose of
recycling and compost initiatives so I
thank the committee for their work and
support thank you any other comments
Representative no wait I'm sorry that's
okay thank you madam chair
um I think I'm just going to
um
concur with everything that's been said
I think that this allows so much
opportunity we've heard in the past how
our elementary schools are really
working hard towards recycling efforts
and composting efforts and this bill
will outline that it will further that
and I work as an elementary teacher in a
school that does do this program through
Mr Fox and I think that supporting these
efforts is really crucial as we move
forward so
thank you representative Bixby
yes um there's also there's some
possibility that uh this uh money will
also be an appropriation listed within
the governor's budget uh they haven't
gone back I
I gave them the information on it they
said they would consider it I don't know
uh but uh if it does if that's the case
then having this a positive vote from
our committee we'll uh give it a
stronger position when this bill goes to
finance
thank you
I request the clerk call the roll thank
you madam chair voting on HB
462-7-a as amended with
20230159h representative Creighton
Clayton votes yay representative yes
represent verbal yes represent Davis
represent brilliard yes represent coulin
yes represent Kenny representza yes
president smart from Bixby yes from the
esophagitis represent dutse yes
represent Murray yeah
yes represent Haskins yes representative
Howard yes there's a NAB represent Morse
representative yes Madam chair Madam
okay that can't go on consent either
because there's money attached to it
so um I am going to close the exec on
hb462 and open up the exec on HB 494 and
oh okay nope representative Bixby yes
I'd like to move on to pass on HB 494
do I hear a second Madam chair I'll
second that thank you representative
representative Bixby would you like to
speak to your most yes this is a a bill
that came out of the study committee uh
on soil conditioners last fall and uh we
um
learned that the uh all the fees from
fertilizer and lime uh are currently
directed to the general fund and uh we
felt that in order to give the
department clearer control over those
funds because they are being charged to
uh programs uh and use they're being
charged to people who are served by the
department of force for the purpose of
of managing that program we felt that it
would be a clearer connection between
the fee and what the fee is doing if we
had those fees go to a dedicated fund
within the Department of Agriculture for
the purpose of administering uh the um
that section of law
thank you representative Bixby any other
comment
representative thank you madam chair
um I think it's extremely important
um as I've spoken before that fertilizer
actually be tested in this state because
with macro and micronutrients not at the
levels it says on the label can have
adverse effects on agriculture
um and that's something we don't want
and it would shorten you know we have
such a short growing season we need to
make sure that everything is proper as
it is thank you
thank you representative come to any
other comment on this motion
seeing none I direct the clerk to roll
call the roll thank you madam chair
we're voting on HB 494-fnotp
representative Creighton Creighton votes
yay representative yes representative
verville yes represent Davis
representative brilliard yes Urban
cooling yes yes from Kenny
representza yes representative smart
represent Bixby
represents represent dutse represent
Murray representing germana yes
represent Haskins Haskins yes represent
Howard
president NAB represent Morse from the
VoIP yes Madam chair chair votes yes
20-0 motion passes
this is another that cannot go on
consent yep so
and while I have you all here
[Music]
um
I would like to uh say that we had
members of our committee
attend a session on what they call craze
c-r-a-s-e
and I would like representative
Creighton to give us an update about
what that was all about
thank you madam chair first of all I'd
like to thank representative Bixby and
Davis who also attended the training and
you two gentlemen could keep me straight
if I missed something bottom line was
about two and a half hours very
professionally done
um by the folks at the state
and I'm just going to boil it down to
uh two things
um one is uh they talked about fire
escape and what we do uh bottom line is
if there's a fire in this building we
take the stairs number one the closest
stairs is go out here you make a left
and you go down and you assemble
um outside the building at which point
will take uh we'll take roll
um
and it'll be it'll be directly across
the street from this exit here where the
stairs are
um so that that's pretty straightforward
and the other one that we spent a lot of
time was active shooter
um and we've all seen the news
um plenty of incidents of where that's
happened and they went through uh quite
a few examples yesterday
bottom line is there's the the doctrine
is that uh you avoid the shooter if at
all possible
then you deny access to where you're at
and then you defend if necessary uh
recognize you that there are no rules in
that fight and then anything we can do
to defend ourselves is is considered
fair game
um and so representative Davis and I
took a look at this room and what we're
talking about is what happens if someone
comes in here and threatens us okay so
the first thing is that the chair and
representative Davis will have a code uh
where representative Davis if he
recognizes something is not right we'll
go outside he'll notify security call
9-1-1 that's his designated
responsibility
uh the second aspect of this is to avoid
and so what we would do in this room if
someone was out in the hall for example
is that um
we turn off the lights
turn off cell phones or turn them down
so they're not Audible
and then we would
um move into this area and that area so
we're not visible from these windows
so that if someone looked into the room
it would look empty
and the other thing we would do is we
would block these doors and by two
no that's good
um so we should recess yes
so we not be if we're talking about what
we're going to be doing in the case of
Senator that's a great Point uh we
shouldn't be
making it making our plan yeah yeah no
no it's a great one at least turn off
your microphones yes okay well so I will
recess uh our our
committee and we will
reconvene later for hearings and I guess
we shut off our mics see you later point
of order can we go into non-public
I don't know no I don't think that we do
that no
so
we'll end our uh our exact session and
our
okay welcome back everybody to
environment and agriculture
I'm going to open up the hearing for
hb119 which is relative to Homestead
and I uh I don't know who is introducing
this bill today I believe representative
coulon
thank you
foreign
thank you madam chair and thank you to
the committee my name is Matt coulon
representing Grafton District Five and
I'm here to introduce House Bill 119
relative to Homestead food operation
licensure The Spill increases the
maximum amount of growth the maximum
annual gross sales of food a homestead
food operation may sell and retain an
exemption from food licensing provisions
and I have my own testimony New
Hampshire is Homestead food laws offer a
Gateway for farmers homesteaders and
abutting entrepreneurs to access their
local Marketplace through Farm stands
farmers markets and Beyond
currently a homestead food operation
producing non-hazardous products is
required to attain a class H Homestead
license if they gross over 35
000 annually
HB 119 would increase the annual gross
income threshold to 70 000 for those
making low-risk Foods meaning makers of
delicious cookies Breads and other Goods
would be free to earn a decent income
supporting HB 119 May create new
opportunities for Family Farms and young
entrepreneurs while enhancing New
Hampshire's agritourism trade let's show
our constituents that we wish to support
their right to live free and prosper by
voting OTP on HB 119 and I'm open to any
questions
thank you representative coulon
um any questions from the committee
representative NAB
thank you madam chair um could you give
me a sense of what the food license fees
are
uh if you make
um high risk food or potentially
hazardous foods you need to obtain a
license for that uh for a homestead food
operation
follow-up I just I meant the amount like
what does
what I believe it's a hundred fifty
dollars thank you yeah
thank you
representative dutzy
yes uh representative coulon are there
any statistics that demonstrate how many
Homestead
producers would fall into this category
how many in other words uh produce over
thirty five thousand dollars
uh DHS does not monitor the gross annual
any other questions representative Bixby
yes thank you for taking my question
uh so uh has uh have any uh in
individuals come forward to you saying
that the
um impede that the 35 000 limit is an
impediment and that uh they need to have
a higher limit I believe we had a online
testimony submitted that said so to the
committee
so I have a question about
the current thirty five thousand dollar
limit
now if someone were to you know start
making Jam or some product in their
kitchen
and or on their farm farm
excuse me and whatever product that they
create
takes off and
uh
you know is is really successful
do you believe that the 35
000 limit
um
is is kind of I mean where would it
where do you think it would fall that
would be somewhere where it would be
profitable for the person to then
maybe move into a another space a bigger
space I mean it seems to me that there's
sort of uh
a a a point where
it is better for them and more
profitable for them to then become a
real commercial Enterprise
yeah
um I appreciate the sentiment of the
question I I mean I think the free
market would kind of determine when you
would want to grow your business into a
production facility and then you know
potentially enter retail marketplaces
and things like that so
um
yeah
okay did I answer your question sort of
I
okay
any other questions representative Morse
thank you and thank you for taking my
question so I'm just
um
curious if it's a hundred and fifty
dollars for the food licensing fee what
goes along with getting the license and
being inspected that is stopping people
from being able to continue making
Breads and cookies and jams how does
that hurt their business to have that
license
uh I believe it
um supporting hb19 would um
help to refocus the regulation to be
more based on the risk factor of the
food produced rather than the gross
follow-up
so how does the license hurt their
business
I mean what
what hurts or helps the business is
dependent on that individual Homestead
representative detsee
uh yes what was the impetus for this
bill
um how was it brought forward was it a
constituent or a a group that was
concerned about the existing law yeah it
was brought forward by a constituent
that's going to offer testimony
representative Howard
thank you madam chairman
um if if you're if the licensing is
are the regulations are based on the um
the riskiness of the food then why are
we talking about the level of income
from the business as a determining
Factor that's a really good question
because it's in the statute and it's
said that it's capped at a certain
arbitrary amount so we want to raise it
representative Howard
so if um so does are you suggesting that
the regulation should be along the lines
of what kind of food they produce rather
than how much of it they produce I mean
in my opinion that would be you know
more helpful but that's just my personal
opinion
any other questions
representative Bixby
so um
is there a reason for a cap at all
uh I don't think so so it would be
actually if a business if someone were
making a million dollars worth of food
uh
in an uninspected home kitchen that
would be just fine
there would be other regulatory bodies
that would come into place if you had
that you know amount of income coming in
and you would also have organically
transitioned into the retail market and
having a production facility and things
thank you you're welcome any other
questions from the committee
representative NAB thank you madam chair
so is the 70 000 is there any basis for
that number or are you just trying to
expand the number
is there any data around Who falls into
the 35 000 to 70 000
or is it just an effort to loosen
regulations I think it's an effort to
heighten the cap on the gross annual
representative Creighton thank you ma'am
thank you for your testimony and your
idea I've got a question regarding what
is it an RSA that what is defined as a
hazardous food
versus on hazardous food is that how is
that defined uh it's defined in the you
know
HHS has like uh seven or eight page
document that outlines all the
regulations for what's uh low risk and
what's potentially hazardous okay thank
you you're welcome
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
and I'd like to call
thank you and for joining us this
afternoon Mr thank you for having me
again uh just to refresh your guys's
memory uh having been here before I
represent the Free State Food Network
which is about 55 people that are
Professionals in the food industry in
New Hampshire so they're making money
off of food uh a lot of them are farmers
homesteaders and uh they're very
interested in this bill I also have uh
more than a decade of experience working
in restaurants and I grew up on a farm
so I'm acutely aware and hopefully I can
answer some of the questions that you
asked the previous person giving
testimony and provide a bit more context
to it and actually I'd like to focus
more on your questions than uh the
testimony that I was really going to
give
um I believe it was asked uh why the 70k
uh big reason for that is the previous
number was too small to remain
competitive
um if you ask yourself uh think about
your own personal salaries in your life
some of you may be retired I'm not sure
but uh is is 70k enough for you to
operate a business and have all this
overhead uh for Revenue because 70k uh
is not going to be taking into account
all that
we need to look at uh the previous uh
legislative sessions uh did increase the
dollar amount once before but the amount
was too small to remain competitive with
the rising cost of Supply Goods uh
supply chain issues Transportation uh
you know raw ingredient costs and just
the uh the inflation of the dollar
uh so in order to remain competitive we
need to raise this amount uh or find
another way to tie it to the rising cost
of goods
um
there was a questionably from over here
about uh what fees are and and I think
what we're really looking at is it's not
so much the actual licensed dollar
amount that is the burden uh it's the
high amounts of red tape so if you look
at the rsas uh if you uh are making over
a certain amount and no longer fall into
the homesteading
operations then you're going to need to
have uh in your kitchen you need to have
you can't just have a normal sink you
need to have a three base sink and a
hand wash sink you need to have many
more inspections of your facilities uh
based around fire code uh based around
just just there's so many different
tests you need to have and different uh
agencies that need to come in and and
check you out including like annual
inspections so
uh it's really the licensing fee is not
the burden there it's the mass amount of
red tape that needs to happen instead
and uh I do think we need to be focusing
on expanding these Homestead operations
uh in New Hampshire uh what we've been
seeing uh the past few years is a lot of
supply chain issues and I think that
focusing on our local economy by
expanding these things and allowing our
uh neighbors to do business with each
other more easier and smoother is going
to help out a lot with that so when
you're going to the grocery store right
now and you're seeing that eggs are uh
however many dollars a dozen you're
spending right now
um I buy mine commercially as a
restaurant owner and I'm paying 40 cents
an egg when it used to be 10 12 cents an
egg
by buying locally and using smaller
local farms I'm actually that I'm
actually uh
insulating myself against these issues
that are uh affecting the entire country
uh so I think that we need to be moving
in that kind of Direction and by
expanding up to the 70k it's going to
allow more of these operations to grow
more of them to be competitive with the
bigger corporations that currently are
controlling a lot of our food chain
thank you so I have a question and I
think I can articulate my question
better this time
with regard to hitting the seventy
thousand dollar threshold yes would the
homestead person
then do you feel be in a better position
financially to move to a situation where
they can afford to get a three-base sink
and all the other things that are needed
for the bigger operation that they have
yeah I I think that that would put them
in a much better position because I do
think a lot of them would love to grow
into a much larger size and and get into
like uh those bigger licenses and in
order to do that they can't just be
scraping by on the smallest dollar
amount that we've already given them
they need to be able to invest in
themselves and grow and uh they do have
um
a desire for some inspections and they
do have a desire for uh increased
testing and that kind of thing as they
grow because as they grow they they're
going to want to have employees and
they're going to want to delegate the
different tasks of their operation and
um
by uh
yeah so through so through that growth
they're going to be looking for uh these
inspections and that kind of thing so
naturally they're going to be looking
out for safety thank you any questions
um representative Bixby yeah so
um under the foods the the foods uh the
homestead food exemption what are the
options for where a person can do their
marketing
where can a person sell if they're doing
if they're under this exemption uh
currently I if correct me if I'm wrong
but I believe it's just out of their
home or at farmers markets and farmer
stands okay and uh do those Outlets
provide
are people running up against being able
to to sell thirty five thousand dollars
worth of
um product at those venues
yeah I do but I do believe they are and
uh I do believe that
um by limiting the dollar amount you're
limiting what products they're able to
sell as well like the farmer that has
the uh cooler uh at the end of their
driveway that's just selling eggs a
dozen at a time uh is going to take a
lot longer to hit that dollar amount
than somebody that for example wants to
sell entire uh cows where you would uh
raise a cow up and sell the entire cow
to somebody and you'll you'll send it to
get slaughtered and butchered and
everything
um so you're really uh limiting their
ability to be competitive with the major
Farms
so does uh the sale of fine of livestock
fall under this exemption
uh the sale of livestock know that that
would not be uh the sort of food but I'm
just using that as as a general example
of uh by that they can't go for a bigger
ticketed items um with their Farm
operations or or selling food and more
bulk out of there or anything like that
representative Haskins thank you for
taking my question thank you Mr Ness I'm
just trying to understand this because
I'm not very familiar with it frankly
um and I'm a huge proponent of
home-cooked food clean food I try to get
all my family members engaged in that
activity because so few people seem to
cook anymore but at any rate I'm trying
why food safety and home food production
should be oppositional in some way
because I think inspections are a good
thing I think home-cooked food and safe
food should be one in the same but if
somebody's going to be doing a lot more
then I have a greater sense that more
inspections will be good and I haven't
seen a I haven't heard the huge
prohibition for licensing other than 150
for the fee well I I think
um
when you're thinking about
why we have these inspections and that
that sort of thing I think uh one way to
One Direction I think that you could
Ponder is how often does your own
personal kitchen at home get inspected
and uh never right you're you're never
bringing somebody in and yet you're not
making yourself sick now we're taking
people that are experts at making these
food and they're trying to make a profit
and they they so they have a huge burden
upon themselves to if they want to make
that money to operate safely and in a
way that's not going to get there uh
they're people sick follow-up follow-up
I I think I appreciate that but if I'm
cooking food for my family I'm
responsible for it I'm not giving it to
other people and taking that
responsibility on so I think there's an
added uh requirement if I'm going to
feed it to anyone
thank you
do you have a question representative
verbal
yeah thank you madam chair uh thank you
for coming in uh Mr NASA I I appreciate
it uh you're in the food service
industry is that correct yes I uh own a
restaurant thank you
what would you estimate the inflation
rate for your raw materials just your
your food raw materials has been over
the last say one or two years if you
could give me a time frame and what you
would estimate the inflation on on those
goods has been to your business uh
like as a percent well it's so it's
really depends on uh
the raw ingredient vegetables have
remain pretty steady you guys have seen
eggs have quadrupled and priced proteins
have mostly doubled in price
um I am thankful that uh I try to be
farm to table as much as I possibly can
and work out special deals with Farmers
to keep my numbers down but uh yeah a
lot a lot of these raw ingredients
people are seeing doubling quadrupling
of prices and I've I've even seen uh
when there have been real supply chain
issues where um
uh before I owned I've only had my
restaurant that I currently own about a
year now and before that I was working
uh I ran uh 12 kitchens four sororities
and fraternities so I was dealing with
feeding a lot of people and overseeing a
lot of different chefs and at that time
uh supply chain issues were affecting us
so bad that we were seeing
um cost of goods uh for example on
chicken uh I would have to go to the
grocery store and buy chicken because
the price was going up so fast from week
to week that uh the grocery store took
longer to update their pricing and I
could save money that way so that the
pricing is extremely dramatic and uh
changes a lot but uh yeah sometimes
double the quadruple in the past three
years I'd say follow up Madam chair
follow up yeah thank you for the answer
I I know it's very tough to to get a
handle on
um you know the the reason for my
question is you know we're looking at
increasing the the amount in sales and I
I certainly am not going to argue with
the the numbers that you gave us on the
cost of foodstuffs going up and so I can
imagine that that inflationary pressure
is rapidly eating into the volume of
material that an independent can sell
before they before they hit that
um it would it would break my heart to
to have to see all the people that have
come out today to have to keep coming
back every couple of years to readjust
um readjust this number so I guess my my
question and and you don't have to
answer it today but I would certainly
love an email to the committee if you
don't want to answer today is what what
sort of what sort of mechanism would you
recommend we put in place
instead of a stagnant number so that we
don't have to revisit this every couple
of years as Market forces sort of force
our hand
yeah I mean that's a tough question
because you could either tie it to some
other value
um or I mean if you if you go completely
outside the system of tying their it to
a dollar amount of Revenue anyway uh you
could you could always
um
provided a completely different license
that just tells the consumer that these
Homestead operations aren't being
regulated in the same ways and let the
let the market decide on its own thank
you Mr Nas appreciate it thank you madam
chair thank you was there a question
over here
so my question is on the 35
000 do you have any idea when that was
put in that RSA
uh the RSA itself we're bumping it up to
35 000. yeah when it when it became 35
000 like what the date of that was I
believe it was within the past two years
and I think it was 22 000 before that or
20 000. okay
so I agree with the form oh so follow-up
follow-up so I agree with what the
former um representative stated as well
I mean it's you know we're going to have
to keep pushing it forward but
um pretty much everything costs double I
come from a I had a restaurant my
brother has six restaurants that were
one was my father so
um it's out of control and it's not just
food it's everything I have a friend
that does a homestead business with
cakes so
um we're seeing it a lot so this is
really about just increasing this so
because the costs are going up for the
most part yeah I mean I didn't even
touch on costs of like actual
Transportation the packaging of things
the cost of Labor there's a huge labor
shortage right now where I lost I I
prefer to buy my Seafood local I can't
do it anymore because uh well I'm
extremely Limited in my what I can do
because uh my local seafood company the
New Hampshire Community Seafood uh just
couldn't find people to transport the
product they couldn't find drivers and
so they just shut down so we just lost a
you know I think when we're talking
about baked goods we don't have to worry
about so much about storage but when you
start to talk about larger Productions I
mean so if I make a dish I can put it in
my refrigerator that's fine if I make it
for 40 of my neighbors there's a safety
issue so
what is excluded as potentially
hazardous food here and what uh so I
don't have the definition right in front
of me but potentially hazardous foods
would be foods that aren't really shelf
stable foods with a very short
expiration date so uh more dairy
products uh food that's going to spoil
and not it's excluding
um like baked goods uh stuff preserves
um Dry Goods like
anything like that
representative Creighton
thank you ma'am thank you Mr Nash for
your testimony uh in your experience
do you have a feel for
how many people have actually gotten
sick on Homestead food
is that does it happen every day or is
it uh exotic I think it's very rare
um personally I think it's very rare I
don't have I don't have hard numbers on
it uh I know that that number would be
tracked out there but uh I really don't
think it's very common uh think about
think about the bake sales you've been
to and you know your own personal
experiences with home homesteaded food
it's really uh low risk food and uh it's
really very fresh food it's not sitting
around very long so it's it's really
uncommon okay thank you
any other questions from the committee
representative Dotsy uh yes thank you uh
thank you madam chair okay so to help me
understand so at the 35 000 threshold
it's not only a 150 dollar license but
you say it triggers a number of other
regulations that would have to come in
play that would cost the um the owner a
lot of money
is that correct and then okay so yeah so
if you're looking for I don't mean to
cut you off but if you look at uh the
the other bill that we're uh relating to
homesteads today 122. if you look at the
text at that I believe there's a bunch
of examples of different uh inspections
that they're exempt from under the home
something and regulations so yeah
there's there's quite a there's quite a
thank you so uh instead of using the
seventy thousand dollars what if we had
stepped regulations so in other words
35 000 or below no regulation 35
000 and one dollar to a number would be
additional regulations but not as own
onerous as what they are now is is that
something that might uh work or not
uh I guess it's worth discussing I I'm
not sure how well that would work in
practice uh
yeah then you're getting into the
territory of making it difficult for
these Homestead operations to
follow uh exactly what regulations
they're supposed to be following like to
understand exactly okay now I hit this
dollar amount now I need to go consult
and figure out exactly what I need to do
and I I really hesitate personally
towards any sort of Regulation that's
going to discourage them from trying to
succeed and do better and grow and if
there's if they're coming up on that
dollar amount and they're thinking
okay well I should try and keep my sales
lower I should try and hold myself back
or I'm gonna I'm gonna get bumped up
into a next a next bracket uh I would
hesitate uh towards anything like that
um
yeah
I I would see that as problematic but
representative Bixby
you need things that uh when the last
time we were considering uh raising this
cap one of the things that came into
play was which products would actually
come anywhere near the cap so I do a lot
of Home canning
um and uh you know and I know how long
it takes in my home kitchen to can
multiple batches of jelly
and I don't think I could get anywhere
near 35 000 even uh in in a reasonable
amount of you know time never mind 75 70
000 doing jellies
um so uh the example that sort of
convinced us that it would be make sense
to raise it uh from 10 to 20 and then
from 20 to 35 in the course of the last
six years was wedding cakes
and that the ingredients for wedding
cakes specifically had increased is that
uh have you heard from wedding cake
producers in terms of their need to uh
to to raise this cap I wouldn't say I've
specifically asked wedding cake
producers but uh wedding cakes also are
a skilled labor so when the uh
when when the cost of Labor is rising
the cost of wedding cakes is also going
to rise and I would ask that
um
if if you don't see uh the dollar amount
I don't know however that but I I think
that if if you don't see the dollar
amount as being relevant
um
uh as it seems to me that you you're
thinking uh then I don't see why you'd
be opposed to raising it anyway if you
don't think they're gonna hit anywhere
near it then what's the harm in raising
um okay so this this is not an
opportunity for debate I just wanted to
get a sense of where you know which
uh categories of the the relatively
narrow set of categories that are
actually allowed under the homestead
food would be running up against the the
money limit
um so thank you for your thank you
any other questions
thank you Mr Nas and I will now call
Colleen Smith from DHHS
good afternoon for the record my name is
Colleen Smith I'm with the Department of
Health and Human Services food
protection section and I'm here to
provide information on House Bill 119. I
just want to provide some clarifying
information so a homestead license they
are allowed to make non-potentially
hazardous foods and as was as as
examples that were brought forth before
cakes cookies jams jellies things that
don't require temperature control for
safety we also things that are acidified
where you're adding acid to make this
shelf Stables because there's an
increased risk of clostridium botulinum
the bacteria that causes botulism with
those types of products
so it order so there are a certain group
of Homestead food operations that don't
require a license and those are that
make under thirty five thousand dollars
a year those that are selling only from
their own Farm Stand their own home or
at a farmer's market or to retail stores
so all they have to do is have uh and
this and then a license would be if
you're making over thirty five thousand
dollars a year selling via the Internet
or if you're selling to restaurants and
the rationale for that is because
there's not in those instances there's
not a direct
Homesteader to Consumer interaction
those they're like a step removed from
the final consumer
um we don't track income so it's
completely an honor System once they hit
that 35 000 and they come to us for a
license we generally find that that's
not the reason they're coming to us for
a license it's because they want to be
licensed even though they don't need a
license to sell to store sometimes they
the store is requiring them to have a
license or they just want to have our
license and inspection
they don't have to have commercial
kitchen no Homesteader has to have
commercial a commercial commercial
kitchen they can have residential
equipment like a two Bay sink that's in
most people's homes or a one-based sink
in a dishwasher they can have a domestic
refrigerator they can have pets in the
home but we just ask that they secure
them away from their area when they're
producing their food so they have very
there's very minimal requirements for a
homestead operation they don't have to
have a commercial kitchen it's only when
you graduate to making potentially
hazardous foods that require
refrigeration for safety or more
in-depth food preparation that you would
graduate to needing that commercial
kitchen so just wanted to provide that
information and happy to take any
questions from the committee
representative erval
thank you madam chair
um thank you Ms Smith for coming in I
appreciate it thank you for taking my my
question
um I got a little confused though
because you kept referencing uh making
and income and I don't believe that the
bill goes to that right the bill is
actually in in gross sales uh and so the
making or the income from gross sales
presumably would be some fraction
thereof of that amount is that correct
or do I have it backwards so it would be
uh it's based on Gross the exemptions
are based on gross sales but we don't
try we don't track that information we
don't we're not asking for documentation
when they submit their license of how
much money they made from their
Homestead food understood just a quick
follow-up follow-up so so it's on it's
on Gross sale of product it has nothing
to do with the profitability of the
business exactly thank you thank you
appreciate it representative Bixby
uh so I just wanted to get a little
Clarity so there's so under 35 000
there's no licensing needed no
inspection or anything over 35
000 uh
you need uh there is a license specific
to that is specifically a homestead
license
that is correct so it is it's a hundred
and fifty dollar annual fee they have
they make an initial application and
there's an inspection that accompanies
that inspection and it's very I I think
most I would hope most homesteaders
would agree it's it's cut pretty
educational in nature
um they discuss labeling of the product
they look at
um you know talk about sanitizing their
equipment and surfaces before before
their production and and how to do that
okay any other questions oh follow-up so
um
so I'm just so uh this is so the whole
and is there any
um Tom any uh cap on how much gross
sales you can have under a homestead
license that costs you 150 or is that
basically whatever you can manage before
you run out of space that's exactly
right there's no cap once you have a
have that Homestead license
um it and again as you mentioned you you
do practically run out of space once
your business grows to that level where
you outgrow your residential kitchen and
need a commercial facility
oh one more okay do you happen to know
what our neighboring states require in
in regards to this
um it is the the homestead food laws
across the U.S are they they vary
incredibly into not only in the types of
foods that are allowed to be made
um where they can be made I don't know
about income level if I believe Vermont
has a ten thousand dollar limit but
um I to be honest with you I they change
laws change from state to state very
frequently so I I can't speak exactly to
what those are right now thank you
any other questions representative
Potenza
thank you for coming to testify I just
had a question in regards with
um you said it's not it's not like it's
policed in regards with the 35
I'm kind of confused then why is it
there
to I to be honest with you
um I I don't I I historically it has
been it has bumped up over time I think
it started as five thousand ten thousand
twenty thousand thirty five thousand we
don't track it and we don't know who is
coming to us solely because because of
income we have currently 133 licensed
homesteads and and so if you it wouldn't
be a significant number even with even
in our amount of license population
follow-up follow-up I did it right this
time
so if let's say someone comes for that
and you find out that they have been
operating above that threshold is there
a penalty or anything like that
we don't have any administrative fines
for that type of violation it would
again this is complete the income is
completely an honor System
um I if it was struck I I don't know
that
um that there would be that much impact
thank you
representative Morse
um so I just want to be very clear so
you can hold a homesteaders food license
for 150 but you do not have to update to
any kind of commercial kitchen stuff
unless you're doing potentially
hazardous food is that correct that's
correct okay thank you
any other questions from the committee
representative Potenza just one other
question
um you were talking about uh in regards
when you get the license
um
when we had our business we were Serve
Safe certified I assume that that's a
requirement correct it is not a
requirement for a homestead food
manufacturer even if they're getting I'm
saying if they get the license now even
if they get the license a homesteader is
exempt from the certified food
representative verbal
thank you madam chairman thank you Miss
Smith it so there's some interesting
questions coming from the other side of
the room that that sort of have me
perplexed as to
um why it is that we have this
regulation so if I violate the
regulation there's no there's no teeth
in the violation so
yeah
it almost sounds more like a a public
education
um
type of
I just I'm not my I guess my question is
if so if I if I'm violating the
ordinance if I'm if I'm uh retailing
forty thousand dollars uh worth of food
so I'm I'm outside I should have the
license and I don't and God forbid
something goes wrong
um is the only downside that if I get
sued by a victim of of my bad food that
perhaps the Judgment would be harsher
because I I didn't possess a license
that I should have I
I mean I'm trying to understand why why
why do we have this if it if it has no
so uh I can I can give you some
historical perspective on on Homestead
homesteaders is
it used to be that all homesteaders were
were licensed
um regardless they they could still make
only the non-potentially hazardous foods
but they all required a license and then
uh I believe it was 2012 we there was a
a law that was passed that Exempted a
certain certain group depending on
income and where they were selling food
those Foods too and then again as it's
been mentioned that income level has has
risen a couple different times from ten
thousand to twenty thousand to thirty
five thousand now but there was never
any it was more an honor System that
again it was understood that once you
started making that amount of money in
your home you were going to need a
commercial facility that that was that's
the intention of the bill was to give
home food manufacturers an easy way to
get started get their foot in the door
without a lot of Regulation without a
lot of upfront costs and then if their
business was successful full and they
grew that they'd go to a commercial
space it wasn't meant to be punitive
that we were going to be the the income
police and looking for who was violating
that it was more a good faith effort to
give small businesses an opportunity to
enter the marketplace with with less
regulation
thank you I appreciate the answer thank
you for coming in thank you madam chair
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony I have one last pink card
for uh Ross Connolly
thank you madam chair members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Ross Connolly I'm the deputy state
director for Americans for Prosperity in
New Hampshire here to offer our support
for HB 119
uh just some background so uh as the
previous uh speaker mentioned in 2011
our state made the decision to establish
a two-tiered system for selling homemade
food products if a single mother decided
to start selling homemade cookies to
make some extra money she would have to
keep the gross uh total revenue under
twenty thousand dollars and she would
not be able to sell in retail stores or
online unless she acquired that
Homestead food license uh last year uh
thanks in large part to the efforts of
The Honorable Herschel Nunes who's
watching online today
the legislator legislature made the wide
decision to increase that limit from
twenty thousand to thirty five thousand
dollars we supported that bill it was a
great step to start to allow these these
folks to to grow a little more since
this is gross revenue not profit they're
not making 35 000 of profit this is just
any money that's coming in
um
as we know businesses can be expensive
to get off the ground uh we we think
moving it to seventy thousand dollars or
or just increasing it uh a little bit
even uh puts these entrepreneurs in a
better position uh to eventually get
achieve licensure and hopefully open up
a store in our communities and start uh
providing a bigger Service uh to to the
state but that costs money uh and and to
have an extra amount of of cash stored
would be a big help for these folks to
hopefully grow that business into that
storefront
um this legislation does not change what
a homestead food operation is doesn't
change any of the regulations they still
have to label their products still have
to put the ingredients on their products
um uh regulation should remain in place
to ensure food safety standards are met
and consumer safety is protected
um just some background on uh I think
there was a question about other states
in the region and across the country uh
according to the institute for justice
since 2015 34 states and Washington DC
have either created uh new homemade food
uh programs or expanded their existing
laws this includes States like Oklahoma
who increased to 75 thousand dollars
Connecticut and Maryland increased to
fifty thousand dollars which I believe
uh the rest of New England is about
similar and Florida has the high water
mark of uh two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars uh who raised those
limits so this is an increasingly
popular business model
um that we believe just needs a little
bit more room to grow and expand uh and
we believe this bill accomplishes that
um just some a little further background
on last year's bill I don't think any of
us ever would have predicted that the
price of goods would increase to the
level that they have over the past year
when that bill was signed into law uh
eggs were probably a quarter of the cost
of what they are now if you're making
homemade cookies or brownies or what
have you that starts to really hit on
how much uh product you can actually
produce to sell uh so even if uh you
know if the committee doesn't think this
that seventy thousand dollars might be
too big of a jump the the one suggestion
that we would make is is uh have it at
least be fifty thousand dollars and
maybe tie it to to inflation uh so that
we don't have to keep coming back here
whenever there's a giant jump in prices
this would allow more flexibility uh for
these these folks to to uh get the
revenue that they need uh so for these
reasons we urge the committee to move uh
HP 119
ought to pass and I'd be happy to take
questions if there are any
thank you madam chair thank you for your
testimony and going back to
representative breville's question I'm
let's say today
I went out there and I sold 40 000.
dollars worth of stuff gross
what happens
is it I mean so what uh thank you for
the question representative uh I I'm not
entirely sure uh the the department who
just spoke probably knows best and if
they don't enforce it then I I would say
uh you know the original Bill last year
was to end the license uh the thirty
five thousand dollars was a a compromise
to just get the ball uh moving give
these folks a little bit more cushion
um but I I can't comment on on why it's
not being enforced or or how that
operates in practice I can say uh
there's been a lot of questions about
what is a non-hazardous food versus a
hazardous food
um so this is from the DHHS website uh
non-potentially hazardous food in your
residential kitchen can be produced
including but not limited to breads
rolls muffins cookies brownies double
crusted fruit pies fruit fruit pies uh
candy and fudged uh packet package dry
goods and jams and jellies anything
really beyond that any uh certainly meat
products or anything what is is a
hazardous food
for a follow-up please follow up and I'm
sorry and it's so
I'm I'm still not tracking what what is
the trigger from going from a homestead
to a commercial
it is that that uh gross so well going
to a commercial kitchen type when your
your kitchen uh kicking in the
commercial regulations that's when
you're going to uh produce hazardous
foods so that's where inspections
commercial kitchen requirements are are
uh expected thank you very much
representative
thank you madam chair thank you Mr
Conley I appreciate you coming in
um two questions if the chair is going
to allow it
based on the information that you're
aware of through the Institute of
Justice would you say that New Hampshire
is lagging other states on where this
cap is set
uh thank you for the question I I would
say we can be much more competitive I I
think
um and it's really in in my view it's
it's not necessarily A competitiveness
it's just giving a little cushion to
these people to just get their business
off the ground
um you know if we if we want to have
more I New Hampshire we pride ourselves
on the amount of small businesses small
restaurants that that people start uh
and and I think it would be a benefit to
the entire state to just have that uh
cushion be be grown so that we can have
uh more people get into that that uh
that industry and have more small
businesses across the state thank you Mr
Colony
thank you madam chair
um
so I I guess I'll because you brought it
up I'm going to ask you the same
question I asked Mr Nash so
um if we were to develop a mechanism to
tie this to inflation
um my question would be and I don't need
an answer today but if you want to
provide a written answer to the to the
committee at a later date after you've
had more time to think about it is is
what measure of inflation would you
recommend right because you got the
Minneapolis Federal Reserve you have the
Bureau of Labor Statistics which gives a
more New England uh type number with
more more breakout than what Minneapolis
Federal Reserve provides do you have a
sense of of what would be a good
Benchmark to tie it to
uh thank you for the question it's a
good question I I
um I can get in more detail and follow
up with the committee but you know
generally tying things to CPI
um is is how any sort of inflation uh
tie to inflation works so whether that's
where we're taking a regional uh CPI
number or or across the country
um you know I I think it'd be worth
exploring and uh just just to see what
would work best I guess great thank you
Mr Conley thank you any other questions
representative Doxie
uh yes uh thank you for taking my
question
um I'm getting a little confused here
because what uh what I'm taking away is
that the 35 000 triggers a hundred and
fifty dollar license annually plus an
inspection
that Homestead kitchen can produce
Revenue half a million dollars two
million dollars the only thing that
triggers another step in the commercial
process is the fact that they grow
outgrow their revenues and they outgrow
capacity okay so Revenue how is revenue
tied to the licensing if we're really
only talking about a hundred and fifty
dollars
uh thank you for the question
representative I think and personally I
think it's more about the incentive that
it creates uh people when when they see
more regulations or or more steps coming
their way they might hesitate to grow
their business uh you know whether it's
enforced or not this is the the statute
and the statute should reflect what
these these business owners need the
most
any any other questions from the
committee
seeing none I want to thank you for your
testimony this afternoon thank you very
much I have no other pink cards as
anybody else wish to speak on this
seeing none I would like to have the
yes thank you you're at 74.
okay um
on our blue sheep we had one two three
four six people signing in in favor of
this bill and one person against an
online we had 74 people supporting this
legislation proposed legislation with
zero opposition
with that I will close the hearing on
hb119
and I'll give our clerk a minute to get
settled for our next hearing for HP 122
okay we are all ready I will open up the
hearing for hb122 relative to micro
Enterprise home kitchen operations and
who do we have here to introduce this
bill
representative coulon
thank you madam chair and thank you to
my colleagues on the committee my name
is Matt coulon representing Grafton 5
and I'm here to introduce host Bill
122. this bill defines Homestead food
operations and provides Food Service
licensing exemptions for them and I'll
read the
methodology back here to explain a
thank you
this bill increases the homestead food
operations threshold from a thirty five
thousand dollars to fifty thousand
dollars in annual gross sales entities
selling less than the threshold amount
are not subject to licensure and
inspection requirements under RSA
143a the Department of Health and Human
Services states that since it does not
track Homestead food operations by gross
sales it is unable to determine how many
establishments would no longer require
inspections or pay the annual Food
Service licensure fee
the physical impact to the state general
fund into which the fees are deposited
is therefore indeterminable in addition
the fee this bill amends the definition
of a homestead food operation to allow
for no more than 30 meals per day and 60
meals per week to be served from a
private home and removes any licensing
requirements for these entities the
department states that for safety
reasons it does not currently allow male
preparation of foods requiring
temperature control and that there will
be no Revenue loss from license fees in
this instance since the operations are
not currently allowed or licensed and I
will yield and open up to the testimony
thank you representative coulon any
questions
I have a question
um so with this bill
if we had passed uh the previous bill
and raised the threshold to 70 000.
would that be out of sync with what
we're dealing with here
of
um this was asking to raise the
threshold to 50 000 from twenty thousand
yep I would save those questions for the
uh testimony
for the person coming after okay thank
you appreciate that
any questions
seeing none I'd like to call Colleen
Smith from DHHS to speak on this
good afternoon for the record my name is
Colleen Smith I'm with the Department of
Health and Human Services food
protection section the department is
currently is opposed to the house bill
122 as as currently written
Our concern is this bill allows the
expands what's allowed in a homestead
food operation to prepare 30 meals per
day and not more than 60 meals per week
as in previous testimony the current
current laws for Homestead food
operations do allow the production of
non-potentially hazardous foods which
are limited to cookies breads jams and
jellies we currently have 133 of these
licensed in the state
are concerned with expanding this is it
does go against our food code which
considers a homestead the homestead in
the food code it's not it's not
recognized we do in state allow
homesteads but we've restricted to those
that are of less concern to food safety
risk this this would Bill if passed
would change that dramatically by
allowing essentially a restaurant could
be run in a home kitchen if it was meant
to have those meal restrictions
the bill doesn't allow us any inspection
or enforcement so there would be no
essentially no oversight that those
limits were being made and attained
there's also concern that this could go
against local zoning restrictions or
other regulations of other departments
considering Plumbing septic
considerations that would be looked at
should this legislation pass
we are concerned with that again
expanding of the types of foods that
could be allowed in a home kitchen there
have been historical outbreaks with food
due to a home kitchen doesn't
necessarily have the ability with a
commercial with a Residential
Refrigerator to cool Foods properly
there have been outbreaks associated
with improperly cooled Foods this again
could allow the door to open to to
Future outbreaks and increase in
foodborne illness I'd be happy to take
any questions the committee has
representative verval
thank you welcome back
um
so I don't know if you have the the bill
in front of you but I'm looking at page
three and
um
I'm starting uh about a quarter of the
way through line 27 local law
enforcement May decrease the limit of
the number of individual meals prepared
based on food preparation capacity of
the operation
but shall not in any case increase the
limit of the number of individual meals
prepared
so it seems to me that this bill has
built-in local control local law
enforcement I would assume could run the
number down to zero and prohibit this
activity from taking place in a
community would you agree with that
assessment or am I an error
so that build that you are corrected
does have that provision that would be
if that Community had the resources and
could effectively enforce that it
wouldn't give the department any
oversight into if the standards or if
those meal thresher holds were being
maintained it would it would it would
rely on local law enforcement to to pick
up that work
does that follow-up sure so
so law enforcement has the the authority
to do uh to enforce local ordinances and
so it would be a local ordinance that
could limit the production and could
limit it down to zero so uh it seems to
me that a community could very easily
disallow this activity if it chose to by
running the the number to to zero is
that I mean I agree it doesn't give your
your department authority to oversee it
but it seems to me there's an escape
clause for any Community by simply
running the number to zero is that do
you agree with that I disagree with that
I believe that that you're correct the
legislation does have a provision for a
local of local law enforcement to have
that ability thank you thank you
representative germana thank you very
much Madam chair thank you for taking my
question compared to your office at the
state level how well prepared do you
think local law enforcement agents
across the state are going to be to
evaluate the suitability of the
arrangements in any particular food
establishment
I I can't comment on the ability of
local law enforcement's ability to
assess what would constitute a meal and
if if they were if they were exceeding
that 30 meal per day threshold as as
laid out in this bill
follow-up uh and I'm also I'm wondering
if uh that if you would say the same
thing about uh their ability to accept
assess potential safety concerns
regarding the storage of food for
example
I am not familiar with the to the food
safety training is of local law enforce
enforcement is I I I would um our our
agency again is is charged with with
food safety in in the state so I can
only comment on on our abilities to
assess that
I have a question
do does our local Health officers do
they take any food safety uh training at
all
so in New Hampshire there are 15 cities
and towns that do have their own health
and health inspector that is responsible
for food licensing and inspecting food
establishments and the other 219 towns
it's not uh it's not their primary
responsibility or are they required to
be to have food safety training
specifically
thank you
representative Bixby yes thank you for
taking my question so
um
on
uh under your reading of this bill if uh
would uh the health departments in
self-inspecting communities have the
capacity to
so the the self-inspecting community
communities they have they have the
ability to make more restrictive
regulations when it comes to home-based
kitchens so many of even though it's
allowed at the state level there are
many of them that already do not even
allow the non-potentially hazardous
foods to be made in home home kitchens
okay thank you
representative burlog
thank you madam chair uh you said you
had uh information regarding uh
past instances of food and board
illnesses with these magnitude
operations do you happen to have the
percentage and and also the percentage
compared to that of a commercial uh
industry
so I uh are my my full testimony has
been sent to the committee and I did
provide an instance of a recent outbreak
it is so since that since home food
production to other to others Beyond
um you know family members is not
currently allowed of non-potential or
potentially hazardous foods there isn't
that specific data available versus a
commercial establishment because that's
representative Bixby
so uh if a licensed establishment uh if
you receive a complaint about a licensed
establishment having given someone food
poisoning you have the authority to go
in there and inspect and figure out what
went wrong
under this bill would you have that
Authority
or a homestead kitchen
so I do not believe that there's any
provision in the bill as written for us
to do any type of outbreak investigation
or foodborne illness investigation
should there be a complaint associated
with the homes based kitchen thank you
any other questions
representative verville thank you madam
chair just to drill down on that a
little bit more
um
so if if a homestead establishment is
selling meals it's you know it's a it's
a commercial operation to a certain
extent right it's a it's a retail Food
Outlet in in that it's a kitchen
producing food the question is for the
the person testifying
so if you've got a report of of food
poisoning from from an establishment
under this are you saying there's no
other provision in current law or rules
that would allow an investigation of
that
that you're aware of that I'm aware of
this would this would exempt them from
our regulation so I would with there
might be other statutory considerations
in our Disease Control statutes if there
was was a public health hazard linked to
it but that that I can't speak to at
this time I can certainly research that
and let you know I I would appreciate
that thank you for your testimony thank
you madam chair
any other questions from the committee
representative Potenza
so just uh to clarify I would assume
that the
um the health department or the the
local
let's say for example example we had our
business in the city of Concord those uh
those laws would Trump this correct
so their laws are regulations in a sense
so I believe this bill allows local
locals to uh to have other regulation to
opt out of of this okay Bill
follow-up follow-up so
there's one piece that's that's talked
about here and I don't know it's just
being missed this is only for same day
so this Homesteader has to produce these
meals and serve those meals and they're
eaten within the same day it's not like
they could be eaten at you know the a
week later or something like that so
doesn't that make a difference so the
the bill is written does provide a
little confusion and I did mention that
in our testimony in a technical defect
because it it inserts uh a homestead
into the definition of of a food service
establishment which means a whole set of
other requirements fall to them but then
it also
it still maintains the provisions of
what our current homesteaders are
allowed where they're allowed to make
foods that can be consumed later such as
a jam or jelly or cookie or muffin so it
it does provide some some confusion
because of the way the the bill is
worded
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony appreciate it and I'll call up
Stephen Nass
thank you for allowing me thank you for
allowing me to testify again here uh
I'll try and be really brief uh this
bill is actually based off of operations
in other states uh California for
example uh despite being a state well
known for having uh heavy regulatory
process on the food industry and just
Industries in general uh is actually way
ahead of us on these sorts of operations
and I think there's been some confusion
today about the sort of uh operations
that are that this is trying to allow in
the state I think put uh representative
Potenza kind of hit hit on it a little
bit but uh an example that I want you to
think of uh if any of you have traveled
in the South or out west would be uh the
sort of people that are stay-at-home
moms or just uh operating at home and
maybe they're filling a cooler full of
uh tamales and bringing them to a local
business and dishing them out to the
same customers every week this is the
sort of operations uh that we're looking
for here where it's it's going to be
primarily people selling a very small
amount of product it is same day served
hot uh directly to the consumer and uh
that that's really what we're trying to
cover here and as far as the
uh enforcement on the local level uh
that is uh what we'd be looking at is uh
towns and cities making their own rules
on exactly what they want to do and uh
decentralizing it from having the state
enforcement of it and I've uh worked a
bit in Massachusetts and that's what I
saw a lot more of was the local towns
having a lot more of a say and in the
inspection process and uh regulatory
aspects of these smaller kitchens thank
you thank you representative NAB
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question so I just want to
clarify it is deliberate that you're
taking control away from HHS and putting
it on to local police officers yes it is
yeah Health Inspectors yes it is and uh
yeah and like I said that's based off of
representative Bixby
so do other states have the police in
charge of this or do they have the local
Health Department in charge of this uh
typically it would be under the
jurisdiction of like the local Town
Council who would then delegate it
either to a worker that's an inspector
or the police or whoever it's like it's
a big variety but it's like the uh the
city government the town government
thank you
representative Potenza
would you say that this is really
helping out the the smaller towns and so
there's less of that um burden with the
DHHS and so it's more that local control
because this really kind of doesn't
apply in the cities I'd say
yes thank you yeah it it would really
apply uh yeah it would help out a lot of
the smaller towns that are a little bit
more impoverished than the bigger cities
uh where there's a lot more opportunity
and uh like I said it's it's a lot of
people that might be stay-at-home moms
looking for a little bit of extra income
uh maybe whatever food they're feeding
their family or whatever family dish
that they're really uh have been making
that's maybe has been passed down from
generation to generation and they're
just they know how to make it in big
batches for their extended family and
they're just expanding that operation
into their community and it gives them a
little bit of extra Revenue stream there
representative germana thank you madam
chair and uh thank you good to see you
again thank you for taking my question
um again I'm going to ask a question
about these amounts are determined how
they're Quantified from 20 000 to 50 000
you've given some examples that I think
that you know we can all get on boards
if there's anyone else specifically can
testify to give us a specific example of
why this twenty thousand dollars is not
adequate why it's fifty thousand it's
not forty thousand it's not a hundred
thousand so could you give me specif
give us specifics as opposed to
generalities yeah thank you
unfortunately I don't really have any
good specifics to give you other than uh
I've done research into what the many
other states are doing and we're kind of
basing our numbers off of theirs um so
if if it's working for them and it to me
it seems like it is uh I feel like we
should stay competitive with those other
representative verbal thank you madam
chair thank you Mr ass for uh sticking
around with us
so the 50 000 is in in gross sales and
so the profit is some fraction thereof
so we're not really talking about
um full-time businesses full-time
incomes this this this this this seems
to go more towards a part-time
side hustle side business if you will
um to to help families that have a
particular skill or or an act in The
Culinary fields to be able to make a
little bit of extra money uh without
actually becoming you know a full-blown
restaurant for the amount of material
that that we're talking about is is that
am I summing this up about correctly
thank you for your question yeah I would
say you are summing that up correctly uh
if if they are trying to make it a much
more of a established business with
branding with employees with uh very
high scaled up operations where they can
really churn out food this isn't the uh
operation for them this is for the uh
the the housewife staying at home this
is for the uh young adult that just
needs a bit of extra income to help them
get up on their feet uh that's who this
is really for this is uh if they're
going to scale up they're going to go
for the bigger licenses because they're
going to be getting uh a lot more
equipment and have a lot more over ahead
thank you follow up if I might follow up
yep thank you thank you Mr Nas for
taking the questions
um
do you have or could you
um prepare a list of states that do
allow for these types of operations I
know you mentioned California
um I have to admit I I was struck by
that
um I found that surprising as well if
you don't have a list if you could
prepare one and send it to the committee
I would be greatly obliged
uh yes thank you I would be happy to do
so and I was also in my research uh
surprise because California is not
exactly known for uh
well there's this sort of this sort of
allowing businesses to grow and operate
like this they're they're really and and
they did take a uh more burdensome
approach than what I uh have designed
here but uh I'd rather not get into all
the nitty-gritty of how they mess theirs
up but they'll learn eventually fair
enough thank you Mr Ness thank you madam
chair representative Bixby
so um
I'm
I I it sounds like what you're getting
at here is actually a different model
than what is currently falls under what
was dealt with as Homestead in the state
and it's sort of like a micro restaurant
uh and that uh with within a house uh
and I'm not sure that the way that
you've inserted into into the statutes
actually
makes it uh I I think it might be
creating impediments for it going
forward uh and I'm wondering if uh you
might also be able to help us with some
references to the laws in other states
and how they have set put that into
their codes to uh to help us figure out
where it really belongs
uh yeah I'm not sure the if there was
like a question or more of a statement
but the uh I would be happy to uh in
addition to sending the list of how uh
what other states are doing I would
happy to send a list of examples of how
they put it into their codes as well and
I think uh this this one would be uh
maybe it's easier to grasp not thinking
of it as a homestead thing but as a
micro Enterprise
um I believe that's it's that's in the
title somewhere but uh yeah as think of
it as a micro Enterprise not really a
restaurant because you're not seating
people uh it's it's more uh take out
kind of oriented
okay thank you thank you
any other questions representative
Morris
thank you
so as a stay-at-home mom and we're
talking about this as sort of a side
business I'm just wondering how many
tamales do I have to make to gross fifty
thousand dollars a year while I'm also
taking care of my kids and my own farm
and all of those things
uh well tamales would be a lot uh and
and I think uh a lot of this would be uh
people selling to establish businesses
where or like you know a building like
this one where they know there's a
couple hundred people in here and uh
that so they can have regular repeat
business and that's how they would
approach that number is by uh extremely
repetitive business of selling to the
follow up
so
how do you see this is like a side
business fifty thousand dollars a year
growth seems like a fairly substantial
amount for a stay-at-home mom to be
making food
uh well I keep in mind it's it's gross
and it's not like what's ending up in
their bank account at the end of the day
in their pocket so right I'm just
wondering what kind of time commitment I
mean you run a restaurant what's your
time commitment to fifty thousand
dollars gross
uh not a lot I would say you can
approach that pretty quickly uh and I
mean tamales as an example is like a
single
individual food item and this bill would
allow for full meals as well so if
you're if you're providing a full meal
you might have a uh sale price of thirty
dollars a meal uh it's going to add up
representative uh Howard
thank you madam chair
um I'm a little bit confused about
what's on page three between you know
the in the uh bold
um italics that you're adding to the
bill
where it lays out the ability to to
produce meals and you know and sort of
sets a a strange set of numbers 30 meals
a day up to 60 a week
um and with no mention at all other than
the raw oysters that that there is a a
two tears to this that's what we've been
led to believe in it and on the next
page it sort of reinforces that at some
point if you're serving hazardous things
if you're serving meals you're probably
cooking with dairy and
and possibly meet and stuff there's no
mention there that that when you change
over from doing cookies to meals that
you need to have to have licensure
or does it say that oh sorry
um sorry about that so I guess I didn't
read it closely enough apologies oh okay
representative verbal thank you madam
chair so
um
so we had cap it 60 meals a week and
those 52 weeks in a year so it's 420
meals a year is my is my cap all right
do I understand that correctly
I believe so if you just did the math
there then yeah great thank you follow
Madam sure follow up so
so 420 meals in a in a year certainly uh
doesn't seem like a super huge amount I
work a full-time job I serve in the
House of Representatives I bet I bet I
could run this gig out of my out of my
houses as well if I was so inclined is
the purpose of the setting the 50 000 to
make sure that they don't bump up
against the revenue cap that they bump
that they max out their build their
business on volume of goods sold not on
not on the value of those goods is that
the intent yeah yes correct thank you Mr
Nash thank you madam chair thank you any
other questions for Mr Ness
so I'm just going to give an example
this was probably about a year and a
half ago I went to an outside event uh
like a little rally and there were two
people there that brought a huge cooler
and um and they had these uh one of them
had these beautiful veggie wraps and the
other one had this other type of but so
I mean they were you know it was like a
donation but everybody was paying for
them in a sense because they brought
them there and um but they're just doing
that so this is like in a sense making
it legal for them to do it really
because people are doing this already
yeah uh thank you so speaking to that I
would say from both directions uh people
are already doing these kinds of things
under the table the the food industry
has lots of under the table work forever
like across the board and uh yeah this
this legalizes it and uh you know brings
it back out into the light so that they
can hopefully uh be safer and do things
appropriately and then on the other hand
in my long experience with uh Health
inspections and seeing inside many many
kitchens uh even in New Hampshire uh
just because uh restaurant or business
is licensed and inspected does not mean
that they're following the correct
practices I have I'm not going to say it
on testimony where but there are
definitely restaurants in New Hampshire
that I will not eat at uh because of the
hazard that's inside them and they are
fully inspected and follow every burden
so
yeah
representative datsy
uh yes Madam chair I just wanted to
clarify what I heard
representative verbal when I do the math
60 meals a week
52 weeks a year I get
3120 meals and I thought you had said
420 or am I correct I just wanted to
clarify thank you madam chair sure uh
just give me a second I I did it very
very quick and I probably did it wrong
and I appreciate the the correction yeah
I I would agree with the representative
across the room it's
3120 meals a year but I will I will I
will stick with my original allegation
that I I could make that work
yeah thank you I don't know if it's not
inspected uh uh thank you and referring
to the the example that the
representative Potenza was referring to
a moment ago right if you think about
somebody who is bringing a cooler full
of tamales or whatever right to sell at
an event
um aren't we now talking about getting
to a quantity Where if there is a food
safety problem we're talking about a
significant number of people possibly
getting ill coming from lots of
different places I mean that's part of
the reason isn't it for having this type
of threshold now raising it more than
doubling it don't we begin to reach a
quantity of consumers where this is
precisely why we have regulations to
deal with health safety in the first
place uh I think that's what the DHS
would argue is that we're getting into
that but I think you would still find
that the amount of illness that this
would increase uh to be a very low
number
representative
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question uh you brought up a
um and what would you say that the
average restaurant in the state of New
Hampshire how often is that inspected by
anybody
well I believe another representative
would like to answer it but uh I'll do
my best they're supposed to be uh
inspected annually uh I don't believe
that that has been always the case
because I have seen kitchens where they
did not seem to get inspected like they
should have but uh yeah
follow up
um thank you for for the answer there
and would you say that if there was
going to be something happening a
foodborne illness or something that once
a year you know a checkup looking in on
a restaurant annually
um and I'm not sure if they're noticed
or not
um they could clean up things pretty
well and then fall back into old habits
yeah I would say that that's definitely
the case
um I'd say that the the
good restaurants the poor restaurants
certainly they will clean up for the
health department or they'll take their
violations fix what they need to and
then carry on with what they were doing
before and there's also the concern of
uh in restaurants with high turnover of
Staff it doesn't matter that the good
staff were there when they got inspected
if soon thereafter it's new people doing
the work and uh not following the
uh representative Knapp
thank you for taking my question I'm
still stuck on the local law enforcement
piece so
our law enforcement have nothing to do
with health and safety and our code
enforcement officer does that but he
barely has time to do the health and
safety piece because he's our code
enforcement officer
um so I wonder if you spoke to any law
enforcement and inserting them into this
picture as to whether this is something
they were interested in second of all it
says can I ask a second of all sorry I'm
sorry can I have a second part okay
um uh it says they can limit the number
of individual meals prepared based on
food preparation capacity but that
actually doesn't really speak to health
safety does it it's a capacity issue I
feel like the language is a little murky
there it's not saying based on whether
they're following safe procedures it's
saying hey maybe you don't have enough
refrigerators
uh yeah so the first part of your
question I have not spoken with any law
enforcement about this the second part
uh I believe the the reason it's worded
that way uh is the safety might not
uh the lack of safety would not
necessarily increase with the increase
in volume but uh the number of people
you can get sick at once uh
does increase when you're increasing
with volume
representative verbal
thank you madam chair thank you Mr Ness
so I want to I want to help my
colleagues on the on the committee and
uh but I I also you know
want to help the people that are
proposing uh such such changes to our
our state laws
would you be comfortable with changing
um who has the authority from
um the local law enforcement uh to the
local governing boardies body say select
board a board of aldermen
um you know whatever whatever the local
form of government is and allow them to
delegate those responsibilities to who
they would think would be best fit in
their communities should they choose to
allow this would would that be uh would
that be a happy medium do you suppose
yeah for me that would be a very
friendly change uh because the intent
behind the bill is to make the local
government and the local community more
involved and decentralize it from the
state
thank you Miss Nash I appreciate it
thank you madam chair
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you Mr Nas
uh are there anybody else who wish to
speak on this bill I have no more pink
cards
you have nobody who has signed up in the
blue sheet Pro or con but online there
were 12 people in support of this bill
and zero opposed
with that I am going to close the
and give the clerk a moment to reset so
that we can now hear HB 493
eliminating the state meet inspection
program
Okay so
493.
okay
I'm going to open the hearing to HB 493
and I would like to invite
representative Bixby up to introduce
this Bill thank you for your
introduction good afternoon Madam chair
for the record I'm Peter Bixby uh
representing uh Stratford County 13 on
Dover New Hampshire and uh
HB 493 is a bill that was brought at the
request of the department uh and uh just
a little bit of background in 2016 this
committee undertook a study committee to
update uh RSA chapter 427 which is where
the Meat Inspection program uh resides
and it resulted in legislation in 2017
to clarify a number of elements in the
chapter including many of the exemptions
to 427 A2 uh
all right 27 2A uh
uh
and uh so a separate bill was also filed
that year to uh create a procedure for
doing exempt on Farm Slaughter of bison
and uh the study committee represented
uh at that point
uh determined that the Meat Inspection
program was not workable at that uh at
that time but decided to leave it in
place because it might be easier to
actually get it operational if it
remained in place a study committee last
year uh that studied the reasons for the
lack of Slaughter facilities in New
Hampshire concluded that establishing a
state level program would be far more
costly than looking into ways to
encourage the USDA to provide more
facilities or help or help EX in sorry I
misspoke there
um encourage more USDA inspected
facilities to start up or expand so
essentially uh USDA will pay for the
inspectors uh for normal time normal
full normal full-time hours
entirely uh for any meeting meet
processing plant uh and or meat
slaughtering plant in the in New
Hampshire uh there is they will cover up
to half of the cost for a state program
and the state is responsible for the
rest of that and that means that the
state would have to find some way to to
get half of the cost of the inspectors
if we had a program uh we probably
wouldn't
we we wouldn't have
uh more than five or six plants in the
entire State and that would there would
be a substantial cost to the state in
order to uh set up the inspection
program and to pay free inspectors it's
just more cost effective to let the feds
do it
um
but because the statue still exists the
commissioner continues to field calls
about how to use it and needs to go
through the whole explanation of why it
doesn't work in more detail than I just
gave you and
uh as a result he requested this bill to
remove it from statute
um having participated in both of those
study committees I was able to identify
which paragraphs needed to be retained
and which could be repealed the sections
that should be retained relate to
exemptions from inspection the on on
Farm poultry and Slaughter exemption is
governed by federal law but also needs
to be authorized at the state level so
that had to be that had to remain
uh similarly home Slaughter and custom
Slaughter for home use need to be
recognized in state law and the on on
Farm bison slaughter provision is
specific to New Hampshire and also needs
to remain
the core description of the state
inspection program runs from 427 3 to
427 32 D and simply needs to be repealed
I considered providing copies of this
that text but it runs about to about 24
pages and I thought that wouldn't be a
good use of resources so
uh
the uh so there are five definitions in
section 427 2 that relate only to those
paragraphs that are being repealed and
those also need to be those definitions
also need to be removed and there is a
faulty reference related to the Bison
exemption that I corrected
so that is what is in the current the
bill currently uh when it was in re when
it was
um
when I received the copy of it uh just
before the deadline for sign off uh I
noticed that there were a couple of
flaws and OLS was completely completely
swamped at that point so
um I said that I would do those in an
amendment and then I uh I haven't
produced that Amendment yet but those uh
that what was missed was in section 427
1A the applicability section and uh this
basically means this section basically
says uh what will fulfill the purpose of
of the requirement for Meat Inspection
uh and
uh the current law reads the purposes
and requirements of this chapter may be
fulfilled for both interstate and
Interstate distribution and sales of
meat and meat products by adhering to
the requirements of USDA detailed in 21
USC chapters 10 and 12. that part should
remain uh the parts that need to go away
are the purposes of this chapter may be
fulfilled but for interest interest
State sale of meat by adhering to the
provisions of the division if off
authorized by the USDA and the purposes
of this chapter may be fulfilled for
Interstate sale of meat by adhering to
the provisions of the subdivision if if
authorized by the USDA uh pursuant to
all constraints established by the USDA
so since we would be getting rid of the
the
um the part of the bill of the law that
deals with us
um in-state meeting inspection not not
through the USDA then we would have to
get rid of those parts of the
applicability and I'd be happy to take
any questions
I have a question
um I I received testimony from Farm
Bureau and they said that they had uh
there's a bill in the Senate SB 23 which
is a study committee regarding the Meat
Inspection program are you familiar with
that uh yes I actually happened to be
wrapping around into the commissioner
when he was about to testify on that
bill and I took a look at the bill
realized that it uh was partly over
overlapping with this this issue and I
went in and uh testified to the Senate
on that bill
and there are a couple of parts of that
one of which was uh essentially almost a
duplication of the study committee that
we did last term uh the other was a
study committee that is specifically
aimed at was termed non-amenable species
uh and so the USDA does it sort of does
um
Certified Inspection for
only a set a set range of species so
um
uh bovine so bovine so beef and sheep
and goats uh but uh there is not
inspection available for uh strangers
otter species like say
um elk or emu or uh kangaroo or I wish
you could conceivably Farm here maybe
not in New Hampshire but you know
further south maybe but so there
anything that doesn't fit within what is
typically livestock is pretty much not
covered by USDA inspection and though
all the types that are con that are not
covered are called non-amenable even
though they some of them are rather
tasty so
um
I when I testified before on that bill
in the Senate I said I approve of the
idea of the study committee for the non
amendable species but uh we think that
the
um part re relating to the in-state
inspection of amenable species does not
make sense
thank you and just as a follow-up to
that so this bill that you've submitted
was that a result of the study committee
the findings that you participated in uh
it was informed by that but it actually
was a result of my discussing it with
the commissioner and the state vet and
uh the other thing about the uh what we
have here in statute is that even if we
wanted to set up a state inspection
program uh at this point the language in
that is sufficiently old that it would
not align with what is appropriate
currently appropriate federally so we'd
have to rebuild it anyway
thank you any other questions from the
committee representative
thank you represent Madam chair and
thank you representative Bixby for
taking my question
um
so what is the harm in leaving this on
the books
um
well
uh I I think that that that's something
that the uh the commissioner can explain
more clearly than I can
thank you follow up
thank you madam chair
um and thank you representative Bixby
um the chair brought up the study
committee
um and during that study committee
although I may not agree with everything
that was said the USDA said that we had
sufficient Slaughter facilities in New
Hampshire to fulfill our needs
at that point
would you say that was an accurate
assessment I I was a little bit dubious
when they said that
uh which doesn't mean that if we if
there were more people who wanted to
either expand their businesses or start
new businesses that they would not be
they would certainly be entitled to a
USD inspector if they expanded to the
point where uh or if they start a new
business
um and needed the inspector
representative Creighton
thank you MC Madam chair representative
Bixby just to try to synthesize what you
just said USA is doing it they're doing
a great job they want to do it we could
do it but it costs us a lot of money and
it would take a lot of effort is that
what you just said yes basically gotcha
thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you very much for
introducing this bill and answering
questions and I call
commissioner Sean Jasper from the
thank you madam chairman members of the
committee I am Sean Jasper commissioner
of the Department of Agriculture markets
and food to answer the very first
question why it's important to get it
off the books is if you believe in the
importance of mental health then you
will support my mental health by
removing it from from the books
um this is a a circular
conversation that occurs all the time
but never with someone who actually
wants to open a state inspected meat
program always with people who want
someone else to open a state inspected
me program
but on a more serious note I want to
thank representative Bixby for bringing
this bill bill forward I think it's it's
time we really focus on the possible
and not
the reality of the impossible
so there's two ways that the 50 that the
feds
um can't won't cover that could be done
that's one through fees
um which would make it
really crazy for anybody in this type of
Market with a small margin to say yeah I
now want to pay 50 of the cost of doing
that our estimate mission is that for us
to run a program on an annual basis
would be in excess of a million dollars
a year
divide that by a very few people who
would be interested in doing this and
you can see that the math doesn't work
the other reality is in a small state
like New Hampshire
where you can literally drive to another
country or another state
um in a very few hours sometimes minutes
um
why would you want to limit yourself to
a market only within the state because
the state the product of a state
inspected program can only be sold
within the confines so somebody couldn't
have a butcher you know a slaughterhouse
and then sell to a market in
Massachusetts or any place else so when
you look at the reality of the value of
a program such as this where we don't
have a sales and income tax to to
support it and there are very there's
zero requests in my five years as
commissioner from anybody who wanted to
build a program like this I think we
ought to be focusing on what we can do
that's why we have our
program the Opera program where we did
receive funding for expansions of
existing facilities I'm happy to say
that closed out last uh Friday we are
over subscribed for people looking for
money to do the expansions I've also
already been in contact with the the
folks at gopher about seeing if there
are funds available so that we can meet
a hundred percent of those requests
we're not talking about a huge amount of
money
um but this is where we should be
focusing and this is a a constant
distraction
from the governor's office I on down I
had to spend quite a bit of time
detailing why this program just simply
doesn't work the Bison uh part of it and
you mentioned Madam chair uh the bill in
the Senate and I agree 100 with uh
representative Bixby on that the focus
is really on the bison and I'll I'll
tell you last year there was a bill that
had been put forth by a senator and then
um my office was contacted about that
bill
and this was to expand the Bison program
to Elk and they said well this this
program with the Bison has worked so
well there hasn't been a single problem
in all these years
I went to the state vet and I said do we
have people that are complying with the
Bison program he said nobody's ever come
forward to me
and there's lab sampling there's a lot
of things come to find out and Health
and Human Services actually
caught it up north that
um bison meat was being sold in retail
stores
uh in contradiction to state law and it
was ordered off the shelf and so the
Senate bill was withdrawn and you know
as we began to have the discussions they
said well this is a very expensive
program because if you're going to kill
a bison you have to have a state vet not
a state vet you need to have a
veterinarian present to observe the
animal while it's alive and then after
it's been slaughtered to inspect the
meat and that becomes very expensive but
that's the only way to ensure that it's
not a diseased animal
so I that's what that study committee is
really about and the only person who was
really there and in support of what they
were doing was actually the person who
owns the Bison Farm
so we're still working on that but let's
not study this issue again this just is
not something that is viable in the
state of New Hampshire
unless you get somebody who's going to
give you a grant of millions of dollars
to keep it going and then I'm not sure
there'd be anybody to apply
mm-hmm
is that also including any programs that
would in addition to what we already
have as far as facilities here
um Does it include educational
components there there is an educational
component
um we are working with Cooperative
Extension on developing a mobile class
now they've come up with the ideal
mobile classroom a 40-foot trailer
and that what they priced out is higher
than what they anticipated we could
scale it back I am going to ask that we
if we're going to do this with federal
funds let's do it right and I'm asking
for that to be filled too but even so
we're probably only talking in the
neighborhood of less than another
um half a million dollars and the
governor has said he expects 40 to 50
million to be that has been allocated to
be turned back and
um agriculture has not gotten much money
out of this huge amount of
arpa funding so I I don't feel bad about
any other questions for the commissioner
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
I do not have any more pink cards for
this uh
hearing if anybody wishes to speak
please let me know
I will read the blue sheet here
we have zero people that signed in in
favor or against this on the blues and
online yes we had seven
who support this uh proposed Bill and
one in opposition
and with that I will close out HP 493
hearing
and give the clerk a moment
to get set for our next and last hearing
okay we're all set I'm going to open up
HP 348 relative to the sale of raw milk
and products made with raw milk
and I don't know who is introducing this
bill
representative coulon
see and you don't even look like
representative Ankerberg
all right well thank you madam chair and
thank you to my colleagues on the
committee for your continued patience
today I'm here to introduce house bill
348.
relative to the sale of raw milk and a
product made with raw milk The Spill
increases the amount of raw milk a
producer processor can sell or process
without a license and removes the
requirement that such ice cream and
frozen yogurt produce using raw milk be
sold in six ounce containers so what
this bill is doing is increasing the
daily amount a raw milk producer could
produce
up to 160 gallons and eliminating the uh
six ounce container limitation and I'm
open to any questions
representative Murray
thank you madam chair uh thank you
representative for taking my questions
um so
I if I remember having considered a
similarly related piece of legislation
before us and part of the conversation
around
the requirement for the the limit on the
quantity uh was with regard to the fact
that um initially uh the testimony was
that this would be a small amount it
would be a tiny amount of of
uh frozen yogurts being produced and
therefore that would be something that
would be limited to small homesteads so
I guess Mike my question is I jumped
from 120 to 160 is quite a large jump
and can you speak to the desire to go
from
20 20 gallons to 160.
uh yeah just if if I'm uh milking my
beautiful Jersey cows and I get more
than 20 gallons I'd like to be you know
statutorily available to sell that to my
customers and to the six ounce container
piece I mean I usually enjoy more than
six ounces of ice cream and frozen
yogurt so I'd uh like to be able to
support my local raw milk producer to
enjoy maybe 10 or 12 ounces of ice cream
or 16 ounces of ice cream and frozen
yogurt
you're welcome
any other questions for representative
of Representative coulon representative
Bixby yes uh so uh what was the origin
of this bill did you have a constituent
who requested uh that uh yes sir uh
constituent request
thank you you're welcome
thank you madam chair thank you
raw milk's a funny thing isn't it it uh
it really strikes a nerve in a lot of
people
but that's not really my question my
question is are you aware of any um
health issues
associated with the sale of raw milk and
raw milk related products uh in the
state of New Hampshire since raw milk
sales were first enabled under a 20
gallon threshold
um I can't speak to the 20 gallon
threshold piece but I can say there is
an issue with raw milk that it makes you
it tastes way too good and it makes you
way too healthy when you consume it so
you might have resistance against
certain you know
maladies or illness that could come upon
you so
thank you representative I actually am
just recovering from such a a malady uh
35 pounds lost in a couple of months
although it probably wasn't the the raw
milk
um
so to the best of your knowledge there's
been no issue no health issues
associated at the sale of raw milk or
raw milk products in the state of New
Hampshire is that correct uh I'd say
you're very correct in that statement
and I'll say that I buy raw milk from a
raw milk producer that has the
six ounce containers to adhere to the
statute and I I don't buy it I stick to
the raw milk because I like to have more
than six ounces in a serving thank you
represent a follow-up if I may Madam
chair sure
so I know a serious concern uh amongst
many and and probably several if not
more in this room is packaging waste I
mean we we hear a lot of testimony about
Solid Waste in the state of New
Hampshire and certainly packaging waste
is is right there would you agree that
selling 20 gallons of frozen yogurt in
six ounce cups would produce more
packaging waste than say 20 gallons of
frozen yogurt that were packaged in
um I don't know say a half a gallon or
or one gallon containers do you suppose
that would reduce packaging waste oh
it's supposed to be correct in that
assessment sir thank you representative
thank you madam chair thank you any
other questions for representative
coulon
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony this afternoon thank you I'd
good afternoon again for the record my
name is Colleen Smith I'm with the
Department of Health and Human Services
food protection section I am here to
speak about House Bill 348 the
department is opposed to the bill as it
is currently written we have we've
worked with this Committee in the past
to expand the amounts of products and
limits
that of of raw milk that can be sold or
made into products without licensing and
regulation but we have serious concerns
about increasing that this to this level
20 from 20 gallons a day per to 160
gallons a day that those are very
significant amounts of animals that are
being milked from a cow's perspective
that could be 20 to 40 milking cows a
day that produce that volume and this
doesn't limit species so if you're
looking at if you're looking at Goats or
sheep that are being milked that could
be five to ten times as much animals
that this this is going and again these
are uninspected facilities there's no
standards for sanitation there's no
standards for testing of the final
product whether that be microbiological
or antibiotics that could be used to
treat the animals this is these are all
going unregulated at this time at these
limits and this again would drastically
increase those limits we have seen
increases in foodborne illness
associated with raw milk since since
this legislation has passed 2016 to 2019
we saw that increase and in fact in 2021
we investigated a large outbreak where
over 50 people from three states and
because this firm abutted to neighboring
states there were also folks from Maine
and Massachusetts as well as New
Hampshire residents that were ill from
consuming milk that was contaminated
with camphobacter that we identified in
the humans and actually in the source of
milk and in one dog too so it it we are
seeing outbreaks associated with raw
milk consumption and in this instance
this farmer was very proactive and as
soon as he received complaints he
notified his consumer base and without
that cooperation this output break could
have been very much larger because if if
an outbreak isn't reported to us
directly we have to rely on a medical
provider to do testing and get results
of that testing and it can take several
weeks before we even know something's
going on and if it wasn't for this quick
reaction of this farmer to notify as
consumers this could outbreak could have
been a lot more than 50 people so we do
have concerns about increasing this uh
this limit also we want to point out
that a lot of up to 40 or 50 percent if
you look at National Data the people
that are impacted by this are children
children under our makeup most of these
at least 40 percent to half of these
cases depending on which data you look
at and and they don't often have a
choice if they're consuming if they're
given raw milk or pasteurized milk so
again we do have concerns about this the
container size that was something that
was inserted into the bill that
originated
a few years ago to limit the amount of
product that would be in a consumer's
freezer over time because there is the
pathogen listeria that can grow under
refrigerated or freezer temperatures and
so that was the that was the concern
about having a larger container size
that that product would be remain in a
consumer's freezer so again I would be
happy to take any questions the
committee has representative Bixby
yeah so um
the limit for uh for someone who is
selling who is not licensed is 20
gallons but I there are Opera I'm sure
the brookford farm sells a whole lot
more than that uh what sort of Licensing
do then uh inspections do they undergo
in order to make sure that their
distribution chain is is working well
so so to clarify the those that are
exempt from license they are limited to
the 20 gallons per day and they're also
limited to where they can sell the
product so they can sell to from their
own Farm or their own Farm Stand or at a
farmer's market as long as they're under
that 20 gallons per day if they want to
sell to a retail store So currently
yogurt raw milk yogurt and raw milk
fluid milk that's allowed but they have
to be licensed by our department so that
involves they do have to have basic
sanitation requirements basic facilities
requirements for floors walls and
ceilings are smooth durable cleanable
and then also they are routinely
inspected and samples of their milk are
tested for bacteria and somatic cell
counts
thank you
any other questions representative
verbal
so I I'm curious what do you estimate
the average family size to be in New
Hampshire
immediate family all right I'm sorry I'm
not an expert in the the family size of
New Hampshire yeah fair enough so I I'm
not either but I I would estimate that
the average family size in New Hampshire
is probably four people uh two adults
and two children so uh to see an
outbreak that would
in fact 40 percent of children and
nobody wants to see children getting
sick don't get me wrong but the forty
percent while it may sound shocking
really if if some contaminated food is
in their family of four uh it would
stand to reason that that half of the
people give or take uh would would be
children
um a follow-up if I may follow up yeah
so you you had mentioned that if we jump
from 20 gallons to 160 gallons a day
that that that would be a lot of animals
which is sort of a relative measure can
you explain to me how it is that the
number of animals somehow plays a role
into what we're discussing here
sure so what could be in a perfect
example is the the campobacter outbreak
that we that we investigated it was
isolated that in that herd which was
about 20 milking cows that it was one
cow that was that was Ill that
contributed that contributed to that
outbreak because all the milk gets mixed
together and so increasing that uh that
volume of cows it could potentially
increase your amount of of
um risk for illness and also these are
are the again these places wouldn't be
under inspection there this would be a
very large operation that there would be
no standards for again looking at the
animal health looking at the animal
conditions where they're stored looking
where the milking facilities are is is
that that also expands you might not in
these very small operations they might
be treating them more like pets where
they're they're cleanliness but when you
get to those larger volume of operations
um it might be very difficult to do to
do that thank you madam chair one last
question if I may one more thank you
could you sorry I worked on a dairy farm
as a child and and through my my early
twenties
um and so it's always interesting what
people's uh sense of scale is could you
give me a sense of scale of what you
would consider a small medium and large
uh Dairy operation
I um and that would vary that would vary
again per person per state
um in talking to New Hampshire though
and talking to our staff in looking at
these numbers they would consider this a
medium to a a probably a medium size I
would say operation at this five the 160
volume of
um
gallons per day thank you thank you
um uh representative germana
thank you madam chair
um
thinking about the size of the
containers and thank you for for taking
my question doesn't increasing the size
of the container increase the the risk
of possible illness in part because it
increases the likelihood that you're
going to eat a little bit now and then
cover it back up and come back to
tomorrow or the next day or whatever
right and so with this milk which is uh
raw milk right so if if it's not
consumed all at once and you have a
larger quantity doesn't that increase
the risk of potential problem
it it could possibly you could um have
more temperature abuse if you're taking
it out and thawing it that gives
bacteria the opportunity to to grow at
warmer temperatures and then freezing it
again it also could limit our ability to
detect a food-borne illness outbreak
because someone might not get sick right
away if they're keeping a container in
their in their freezer for longer
periods of time versus consuming it and
then getting ill you know immediately or
shortly after
representative Bixby yes uh just curious
was the operation uh where the capital
of actor uh outbreak uh took place was
that a licensed and inspected facility
or was that a uh something uh farm that
is operating under the homestead
exemption so that was that was a
licensed facility and and again that it
doesn't because this is a raw product
there's no there's no kill stop there
it's not being pasteurized so even in a
licensed facility things can things can
go wrong again I can't tell you enough
is that our relationship with that
farmer and them being able to contact
the inspector right away let them know
it it was allowed us to get the word out
do the investigation and take that
intervention to get further people from
becoming ill follow up so um so if for
uh unlicensed operations would the
response time be slower or or perhaps
non-existent if if there was an outbreak
that is possible because they would not
have that relationship with with our
inspector to know who to contact or or
maybe would be concerned and worried
about what's going to happen so that
they might be less likely to report if
they were receiving consumer complaints
that their product made someone ill
thank you representative verbal
thank you so so based on everything I'm
hearing it would it be safe to assume
that the preference of the department
would be to repeal the raw milk uh
legalization in New Hampshire and and
return to the days of 100 uh pasteurized
milk in the market
I I'm not going to comment on that full
question I can tell you that we are
opposed to this bill we're opposed to
expansion and that we don't Advocate the
consumption of raw milk because of the
public health risks quick follow-up
quick follow-up were you where was the
department also against the original
bill that allowed the 20 gallon limit of
raw milk and raw milk materials into the
marketplace that bill was in 2012 I
believe and I I cannot recall if the
department took a position at that time
okay well go ahead representative
cuomtoire then
uh thank you madam chair and uh
representative verville at that time uh
the people that crafted the legislation
on the raw milk work worked diligently
and closely with New Hampshire DHHS who
representative Bixby
so and also I believe that uh you know
there was some modification to it in
2013 or 2014 and at that point uh I
believe it was Mr Dumont was the um head
of uh food protective services and he
explained that the reason that we keep
with small amounts is because uh it we
it's it's a risk reduction
um
Factor so if you're producing very large
amounts the risk multiplies
substantially and with so the department
was happy with small amounts of raw milk
because it was a constrained risk
representative Murray
thank you madam chair for taking my
thank you license no longer be sought
how many times do you go into a facility
to inspect is it annually biannually
um and by not having the ability to do
that obviously there may be other risks
Associated so could you speak to some of
that so so depending on the type of
dairy operation they could be in
um
there are certain those that ship across
state lines those are required to be
inspected at certain frequency their
pasteurizers are required to be
inspected monthly
um for just to sell raw milk at retail
those would those producers would be
inspected every six months
oh what
kind of questioning then would that
potentially limit a Farm's ability to
transport their milk outside of state
line if there would be no requirement to
inspect for sanitation so so in this
instant so raw milk cannot trans raw
milk cannot be transported us across
state lines if it's going to be consumed
in that state that's that's against the
federal law
any further questions representative
verbal so you spoke of an outbreak
earlier that involved three states from
one Dairy location presumably the dairy
location was only located in in one
state
so
so the milk was illegally transported
across state lines is that so so in this
instance the farm was in New Hampshire
but the consumers went to purchase the
the milk from that farm directly and
took it back to their home so there
wouldn't be they weren't going to resell
it that's that's the illegal part of if
somebody is free to go and purchase a
product in another state and bring it
back to their their home thank you
okay
any other further questions for
Miss Smith no seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony this afternoon I
have uh calling Stephen Nass
thank you for hearing my testimony yet
again uh I'll be brief I'm so I'm
originally from Wisconsin which is the
Dairyland USA and we've fought a lot for
raw milk Freedom there and what uh I
noticed was uh a lot of the language in
uh the legality of raw milk is really uh
not due to safety because I believe that
the consumers do understand the risks of
drinking raw milk it's really uh
anti-competitive behavior on behalf of
the larger milk boards and milk
producers so the two things that this
bill is touching are changing from 20 to
160 gallons which is the equivalent of
having a couple of cows to having still
just 20 cows is not a huge increase and
I believe that's still considered and
where I come from that would still be
considered a small dairy farm and then
again
increasing or removing the limits on the
size of the container from six ounces uh
again I believe that
the reason why the size of the container
is really not based on increase of risk
it's really based on the increase of
competitiveness or the the changing
competitiveness because when you go to
the grocery store how many six ounce
containers of regular ice cream do you
see uh you really don't see them there
you're buying it by the gallon you're
buying it by the the full Pint or a half
gallon or a quart so that's really the
ultimate reasoning uh even if the health
department might disagree
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question uh you mentioned
um that increasing would go from like a
couple of cows to about 20 cows what
about goats because goats are part of
the raw milk bill so how many goats
would you need go from to in regards to
this I'm not positive I'm not as
familiar with goats and uh but I would
assume the percentage scale would be the
same so I'm really not sure that yield
on goat milk
hmm
okay uh any other questions
gallon to a gallon and a half a day
thank you representative Creighton
so if you go from
warning
and so what you're saying is a cow
produces eight
eight gallons of milk per day yes
any other questions representative
verbal yeah thank you manager thank you
Mr Nash uh for taking the question
um
what I understand you support the bill I
and I don't I don't disagree with you at
all
um would a um friendly Amendment be
amenable to you to
um change six fluid ounces to 128 fluid
ounces uh basically making the upper
limit a one gallon container would that
be
would you find that to be acceptable
yeah I mean that would be acceptable in
some ways
um yeah I I because like I said the the
my main opposition to the numbers that
were originally uh included would be
because it's just they're just trying to
not let the small producer compete with
the big one and the dairy industry is
dying in the United States this at least
on the small level it's more and more
just the big farms that are able to
compete and the small ones are being
pushed out
and thank you Mr Nash I can't argue with
that we're as a former Dairy Farmer
we've certainly seen at New Hampshire
thank you madam chair
representative germanna thank you for
taking my question again but if your
contention is that raw milk is is just
as safe as uh milk that's been
pasteurized or that the the risks aren't
uh any greater why would you agree to
any amendment to limit the size of the
container in in the first place uh
that's not what my contention is I do
believe there is a greater risk in
drinking raw milk uh I but I do believe
that the consumers know and understand
that risk when they purchase it you're
going to May a follow-up sure then but
again so my question as as some other
questions on some other bills is you
know what is the limit that you would
set what is it based on what is the
science what are the studies that
determine the specific upper limits that
you have suggested
and I have the upper limits at all
I mean personally I don't believe there
should be upper limits I think that uh
consumers can make that determination on
representative Murray thank you
um Madam chair for taking my question
um thank you for taking my questions so
one question I have is that um I think
sort of in similar vein as
representative germana
what types of illnesses are you familiar
obviously we know that can't pull back
back door is they a an actual bacteria
but what what sort of risks come with us
um drinking that milk to like for
example children for example do you know
what types of illness they are faced
with if they are um become ill because
of consuming these products yeah uh I
don't know the bacteria names off the
top of my head but the and I don't know
how much more of a risk of actually
catching these things children would be
uh they just don't have the stronger
immune systems an adult would but uh
basically it would be any bacterial
contamination or a chemical uh
contamination for example uh you're
washing the tank out that you keep the
milk in and use bleach and you don't
properly rinse it and that gets into the
milk and contaminates it
representative Murray follow-up thank
you so the event that and
ancient inspections were not to occur
and children are at a higher risk for
for diseases and and things associated
with chemical Factor I'm sorry I'm
mispronouncing that
um what What treatments and what
protocols would then happen as a result
of I think Temple bacteria causes severe
diarrheas dehydrations all sorts of
other types of things associated with
that and when you're looking at children
do you have any idea of the implications
that are associated around illnesses
that result in sort of those types of um
diarrhea dehydration etc those types of
things like the implications on the
health effects on the children
uh I'm not I'm not super familiar with
like disease
control and the effects of specific
any other questions for Mr Nass
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today and I call
um
The Honorable John T O'Connor to come
I only have a small room you get double
size
again my name is John O'Connor I'm
living Derry New Hampshire
and little thing about my background
before I go in and I know it's late you
hit a very busy day
uh I've been in the dairy industry for
over 50 years started out on the farm I
went to an agricultural high school went
to an agricultural College I mined it in
pathology for the dairy industry style I
was a laboratory technician for a couple
of years at HP Hood spent 20 smart years
with them then I got promoted and then I
got stolen by another company became
vice president of operations and quality
assurance
and I kept their used classes now
I want to go back in a little history on
this hill we've come a long way to get
to where we are and I know I wrote
support on that but I'm starting to
maybe change my mind after listening to
some of the conversations going on I'm
going to tell you why in a minute
we had a meeting back in February 2nd
2020 when I was still here HP 1592.
and we all got together including
commissioner Jasper HHS Farm Bureau
representative Aaron was there remember
and Senator Pearl was down there also
and
we ended up voting 19-0
in the committee went on the consent
calendar consent calendar went over to
the
from the house to the Senate
Senate under their dubious ways because
of all the on the bus bills they were
doing at the time
is that they threw it all in a big
packet and on top of it said
consent calendar table and this bill
here 1592 was in table and never had a
hearing
and I want to go into the reason why I
limited the container size
had huge hearings both in the house and
in the Senate
Senator French he amended hb95
addressing a labeling issue which we
didn't have that we were going to do
to a table that and so the one of the
key elements in the labeling issue was
stating consuming raw milk may increase
your risk of foodborne illnesses
foreign
So I listened to
commissioner Jasper and HHS
and some of the suggestions maybe is
if we don't want to do licensings
because they want to stay exempt then
let's take a look at maybe somehow a
regulatory uh
documentation or registry
because at that meeting new in HP 95
commissioner Jasper says he has no idea
how many farms they've either making or
selling or I know
so at least this should be excuse me
there should be some type of
documentation so that if there was a
major break outbreak then they could go
I still believe you should have it once
one of the things that I did when I was
vice president of operation I also
belong to an organization which is
called the National Conference of
Interstate milkshop is which is 50
states plus some International countries
that have both Public Health Department
of Agriculture in Industry with an
oversight from FDA and when listeria
started getting serious with um
within the industry especially when the
study first came out from the University
of Vermont that listeria can survive
freezing temperatures
so we developed good manufacturing
practices
we developed tacit which was Hazard
analysis critical control points and I
would think somewhere along the line we
would need to take a re-look at this
here
representative verbal
a friendly Amendment about raising the
quantity size
I would be absolutely against that
whatsoever I know I put the six ounce
size in So based on studies that I was
involved with with FDA over the years is
that if you even have a half gallon
and you have cows sheep goats and any of
those mammals that shed listeria and not
only do they shed it but listeria is
also found naturally out and it's
ubiquitous throughout the soils and it's
an environmental bacteria
and I read the reread the document from
the goat person that testified on the
Senate last year where she explained how
they took a bucket of milk and then put
it in a refrigerator to try to cool it
down because it's usually at uh memo
temperature so you have a chance of
growth if you get it either by
environmental because of smaller
locations aren't capable probably as
some of our big facilities that I had
where we segregated raw systems from
pasteurized systems and we even had
maintenance people we had different
color clothing so they would not
cross-contaminate
so there is a concern on that so my
leaning is that since
hb95
was just signed by the governor in July
I believe of last year
why don't you give it a chance
and
monitor it because you can always come
back in January the following year and
I'm changing my position from support to
I'll either continue to put in an
interim study
because there's some other little minor
things that I can send you later
regarding that um
some of the definition is going to have
to be changed
you need one of the definitions a milk
producer distributor that sells raw milk
greater than 20 gallons that needs to
get into 184 38 because some of some of
the other rsas the small little things
but they don't coincide so to clean this
whole thing up you need to go back and
look at some of the other rsas and as a
conjunction that and I don't know if you
have a researcher here that can still do
that
so that that's what I've
I want to say because
I know you guys have been here for a
while
and again
going back on the container size one
more time
because if you have little kids at home
or a pregnant mother
and you take that container out and it's
a half gallon or well most of them not
that you got cheetah bottom so they're
probably you know 36 ounces of something
so uh it's on the uh on the counter and
there's a birthday party going on eat
ice cream melts and everything else
bacteria is growing
and put it back in the freezer bring it
back out same thing and again when they
make the ice cream that's the same thing
too because I had Blast Freezes on my
ice cream as soon as I packaged it
whether it was in a three ounce six
ounce or three gallon the three gallon
even within 20 minutes was frozen solid
but we had that type of equipment these
other equipments were small locations
their freezes are they uh zero degrees
or are they at minus 15.
So the faster you freeze it you know the
less chance you have any growth of the
bacteria
so with that I thank you for inviting me
to come up it's been a while since I've
been up here and
it's nice to see what's going on it's
great to have you back in the building
we have any questions from the committee
on this
representative Potenza
since you seem like you have the history
and you're an expert on this do you even
have any idea of what the numbers are of
raw milk consumption in the state of New
Hampshire because I've literally never
had it so did do we have a uh a
documentation that comes out on a
monthly basis and it all gets reported
now I don't believe the raw milk does
get reported but the federal government
the milk it's called the Milkman kellara
and in there they break it out by
classifications whether it's class one
milk which is sold at retail level uh
class two class three which becomes a
what's called a blended product that
usually ends up going into uh powdered
milk and the farmers get less money for
that
so the best thing to do is everybody
start drinking no from the retail level
so it's a pharmacist because before I
left both the commissioner and myself we
did our damn this to try to get made in
New Hampshire labels we had that and we
were going to get enough money to put
individually to automate we're trying to
work for hoods over here in the conquet
follow up
yeah I just because it's just an area
that I'm not um you know I just don't I
don't know much about it I I would
assume if you're drinking raw milk if
you're a parent buying it in your in
your house like
I don't know it just seems to me it
wouldn't be something that would be left
out on the counter you obviously know
you're saying that you guys put the
label on there I've never had raw milk
so I just I don't has it has it been an
issue I mean you said it was an issue in
a commercial but the DHS commercials was
the capital Baptist at first I've heard
about that here okay but last month in
Florida there's a huge huge recall going
on in listeria and but that's typically
would be followed by an environmental
issue typically ventilation systems
drains anything that has the moisture
inside refrigerators and so forth
they can cross-contaminate that way
representative Bixby
I'm back thank you representative so um
I'm wondering about the the increase uh
for an uninspected facility going from
20 gallons to 160 gallons and I'm
wondering and one of the things that we
heard in committee before was that the
uh the extent the the quantity of sales
uh increa the the more the more broadly
you sell the greater the risk there is
I'm not even and and also in terms of
you know the if you're pooling all of
Vienna all of milk
um the more animals you have pooling
into one uh bulk container uh the more
if one of the animals is sick then you
have a greater risk I'm wondering what
you think about you know whether that
jumped from 20 to 160 makes sense
whether you think there's any jump makes
sense or whether you think it's probably
good at doing it I would say stay with
hb95 and keep keep the volume at what it
is at this point in time
and because basically again when she
testified over on the Senate side uh
small farmers they're not going to have
a bulk tank they usually have stainless
steel pails and then they can carry you
know five or six gallons that way there
from from her her testimony and how she
handles her phone and it was it sounds
like it's it's you know the global gold
standard she was doing an excellent job
thank you
representative Murray thank you madam
chair and it's wonderful to see you
again just for a little Personal
Privilege I served with you on hb617 so
it's great to see you back still
following you on your way thank you
especially composting yes thanks so much
on that one
uh says they don't have the ability to
detect those two types of bacteria
that's an odorless type of bacteria or
is it not like could you smell it and
say oh this is off no you can't you've
got that like you say this is listeria
can't live back to Yesenia uh and then
the other one that's really nasty but
typically it's mostly going into the
hamburgers is the E coli over there that
one but with little kids can create a
depth on that one
see you representative verval
thank you as uh we'll have to take this
question
nice to see you uh Mr O'Connor
you're my first chairman you taught me
well I think
um my as a former victim of chemical
doctor my understanding
um from the CDC because I went to the
hospital for being sick and it's a
mandatory report so the CDC uh called me
up and they said the Number One Source
Capital factor is intermingling of human
feces with food
so that that's what they told me I'm not
saying it can't occur in in milk
but I it's not a question just I just
did you say that there's a requirement
to label raw milk that consuming raw
milk may increase the chances of is
that's a current requirement yes okay no
you don't have to look it up I'll take
your word for it uh Mr O'Connor I served
unto you I know you to be a very honest
and honorable man 180 484. it is nice to
see you again thank you madam chair
any other questions for
Mr O'Connor no seeing none thank you so
much for coming in today I'm pleased to
see you again here
thank you nice awesome I've run out of
pink sheets for this um Bill anybody
else interested in speaking
seeing none
uh on the blue sheet here we had six
people in favor of this bill
online we had 69 people in support and
one person in opposition for this
legislation
with that I'd like to close HB 348
and that ends our hearings for this
afternoon
we will be meeting again next week
we will be having a work session in the
morning
for the agriculture policy subcommittee
to talk about hb221
and then we will have a
committee work session all of us at 10
o'clock to discuss HB 326 the
rodenticide bill
and we plan to after that work session
to exec the bill
and then we'll have lunch and then in
the afternoon we're going to be hearing
HB 37
and hb231 one is the the groomers dog
groomers
legislation and the other is the cat
declaw bill
so
we'll have uh that that is what is
planned for next week and I hope to see
you all I hope you have a wonderful week
and think about all we've heard today in
yeah I'm I would um I do want to work in
some caucus time for each of our
caucuses to discuss
executing those bills so
it's possible we may have instead of uh
for for the committee work session we
may break that off a little early to
meet before we do the exec of the bill
yep
right no we're not going to expect that
so I'm going to close uh close out our
committee meeting for today thank you
all